churches burn monks run from axe
wielding Warriors hopped up on who knows
what the Vikings steal and pillage and
burn and kill then they take it all and
sail back home just in time to celebrate
the holidays in ancient Scandinavia a
group of Norse Raiders are celebrating
the glory and paternal wisdom of their
god Odin and burning great logs as they
drink their Mead in High Spirits however
even the thunderous sounds of Viking r
cannot disguise The Telltale click of
gnarled feet on the snow covered roof of
their long housee on one of these winter
nights these seafaring Raiders will see
their own home be raided by an unwanted
and cruel visitor a twisted humanoid
Beacon of malevolence that has
terrorized the Northern Hemisphere for
thousands of years but where did it come
from and just how far back does its
history with the human race go we we're
now in the 18th century a sleepy Village
in Denmark prepares to celebrate the
upcoming days of Ule firewood is chopped
and laid neatly at the hearth in every
home and white snow covers the ground in
their state of festive cheer the local
population is oblivious to the grizzly
whis kned event that will befall them
before 12 more nights Pass By The River
an elderly man scans The Horizon for
something just out of view his name is
Emil schroer and he remembers seeing
over 70 Ule celebrations in his time he
is the oldest living member of a family
that has inhabited this region for
thousands of years ever since he was a
young boy Emil was aware that this
season of cheer brought with it both
childlike wonder and pure abject Terror
when he was 9 years old Amil lost his
best friend Noah to what was thought to
be an incident of banditry Noah and his
family had lived in the house next door
to ails and with the village being so
small their friendship was practically
guaranteed the two boys played together
all year round but especially during the
winter that was the time that Emil and
Noah would build great snow forts and
act out the Viking battles from the
stories their parents had told them the
winter that Noah went missing was marked
by peculiar happenings including a
situation two nights before when the
boys swore they could see an additional
snowman they did not build on the
hillside where they usually played it
was taller and more thin than the other
snowmen and from a distance it appeared
to be covered in dark coal whatever it
was the boys were unable to find it when
they went on the hill the next day the
strange dark shape was regarded as an
utter mystery to them and a product of
Boyhood imagination by their parents
only after the Sinister events of Noah's
disappearance did AAL begin to connect
the unknown snowman with one of the more
outlandish Viking folktales he had heard
there was nothing So Glorious about the
night itself which claimed the lives of
Noah's mother father and Uncle all three
adults were found in the same room of
the house covered in a myriad of wounds
that were very clearly the cause of
their sudden demise whoever or whatever
had done this to them had obviously
taken their time to avoid delivering a
killing blow too quickly but before we
explain a question for you is something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
regardless if you have a clinical mental
health issue like depression or anxiety
or if you're just a human who lives in
this world who is going through a hard
time therapy can give you tools to
approach your life in a very different
way and that's why I'm excited to tell
you about today's sponsor better help
better help's mission is to make therapy
more affordable and more accessible and
this is an important Mission because
finding a therapist can be really hard
especially when you're limited to the
options in your area better help is a
platform that makes finding a therapist
easier because it's online it's remote
remote and by filling out a few
questions better help can match you to a
professional therapist in as little as a
few days it's easy to sign up and get
match with a therapist there's a link in
my description it's betterhelp.com
slcp explained clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you 10% off your first month of better
help so you can connect with a therapist
and see if it helps you and because
finding a therapist is a little like
dating if you don't really fit with that
therapist which is a common thing with
therapy you can easily switch to a new
therapist at no additional cost without
stressing about insurance who's in your
network or anything like that so if
you're struggling consider online
therapy with betterhelp click the link
in the description or visit
betterhelp.com
sccp exlained thank you again betterhelp
for supporting this Channel and now as
we were saying about Noah and his family
it was not uncommon for Bandit groups in
the region to initiate violence in their
attempt to pill for goods from their
targets but sism on this level was
almost unheard of what was also
distressing was that no other house in
the village had been hit and no
possessions were even taken from the
house of Noah's family the brutality of
the adult's Fates would almost have felt
more like a random act of nature the
attack of a wild animal if it were not
for the clear and deliberate slashes on
the corpses that had come from some kind
of manufactured weapon and yet the event
was still considered to be the work of
Bandits for although the livestock and
family bobles were not Disturbed Noah or
what remained of him had been taken far
away from the village there were some
who thought he had been taken to be
raised into banditry or perhaps sold in
some unsavory place as a child's servant
Emil his parents and the rest of his
village mourned the loss and lamented
the potential fate of the child but
could find no way to seek Justice
against the perpetrators but Emil never
forgot how sudden and unexplained the
event was and as he went through life
there was always an additional chill
that he felt when the U tide season
rolled around when he was 25 years old a
similar incident to the loss of his
friend happened in the village this time
it was the family with two children and
once again the child younger than nine
had gone missing Emil almost could not
believe it a near mirror reflection of
the worst trauma of his childhood
repeating in his present day once more
The Village buried the dead and mourned
for the missing child Amil offered his
condolences but held his tongue about
what he saw as parallels between the
abductions fearing it would only cause
his community more pain to remember the
dark Ule 16 years ago in his heart
though he was more convinced than ever
that something old and evil was a foot
the unknown perpetrator was more than
anything else patient and so Emil knew
that he had to be patient too if there
was an answer to all of this he had to
believe it would reveal itself in time
the intricacies of the mystery offered a
purpose beyond the mundane to a meal and
for decades he lived a quiet life in the
village astred the woman he married had
been previously courted by a wealthy
Merchant from Beyond the region who
became displeased once the two of them
had difficulty producing a child when
the merchant ran off to find another
prospective bride without leaving her so
much as a golden ring poor ASD was left
socially and financially ruined she was
in deep sadness and felt she was doomed
to become the unwed Village hag but Emil
understood loneliness as well as any man
good in the close-knit little Hamlet and
saw fit to visit her and share his money
and food with her until their love
blossomed like the spring arriving
through melted snow together astred and
Emil lived a happy life despite or
perhaps in the back of Emil's mind
because of her childlessness the humble
married couple contented themselves with
farmwork and perfecting recipes for
seasonal treats several years into the
marriage ail told astd of his troubled
childhood and and the tragedy that took
place next door to his family home where
the two of them now lived astred
comforted her husband and shared his
grief and because of this Emil was able
to begin the healing process in his
adult life for a time he believed that
it was all over and that the deaths in
The Village's past could be forgotten
decades later at age 48 he was forced to
confront the reality of those events
once more a new family had moved into
the village that year to raise their
newborn son in a thriving Environ M this
would have been their first Ule in this
new home and unfortunately it was their
only one as well again there was no sign
of the young child at all but the bodies
of the parents were found in
indescribably brutal condition within
the same room of the home in the years
that followed Emil nearly lost his mind
and began to drink Mead heavily in order
to numb the creeping Sensation that evil
had been watching him his entire life
astred was concerned but despite her
best efforts she wasn't able to assuage
Emil's paranoia Emil schroer became an
unkind man broken by his past and
unwilling to fully articulate the depths
of his feelings on these recurring
tragedies his me addled mind would turn
over the same thoughts every day of
every month why does it keep happening
to this Fage why am I the only one who
seems to see the connection and most of
all was the story of our ancestors in
the Ule monster actually true these
thoughts became especially om minent
every winter and Emil became known to
all as a man who would rant and Rave in
Tales of bloody conspiracy if given a
chance there were many times where
astred thought she would leave him but
stayed because regardless of his me
consumption and maladjusted ways Emil
was the one man she had ever been happy
with she remained his wife for another
10 years until sickness took her now
completely alone Emil Schroeder was
practically a living ghost haunting the
home where his long since deceased
parents had raised him without ASD or
any relatives to help him run the farm
stand his personal funds dwindled until
he could barely afford to keep Bread on
his own table The Man became shrewd and
withdrawn but kicked his vices to the
curb in order to live on this was
particularly out of love for the wife he
had lost who he knew who would have
hated to see him suffer so he dreamed of
her often as well as Noah who is
perpetually a boy in the tales told by
his subconscious as Emil Grew Older
still he was sometimes confused and
misremembered himself and astred raising
Noah as their son before remembering the
truth of the matter and why the death of
one led to his association with the
other it was during the winter months
when Emil Schroeder was the most active
handing out sweets to every child in the
village and giving sincere but solemn
warnings to their parents he would
Patrol the streets like a militia man
keeping an eye out for anything out of
place like that Snowman from his
childhood a memory that he kept all
these years despite so much changing
around him this brings us back to a
72-year-old Emil schroer standing on the
side of a river he watches and waits for
the arrival of something that he barely
can comprehend an embodiment of evil
that never strikes when expected if his
viil could prevent even one crisis then
it would be all the worth it when all
was said and done all day Emil stood
there until one of the children from
town came and approached him old man
schroer said the boy are you cold AAL
turned and saw that the youth standing
behind him was no more than 7 years of
age every time the familiar tragedies
happened in the hamlet there was always
a child younger than eight Emil examined
the face of the boy until his mind
willed the words from his weary lips
what is your name child said Emil
Frederick sir the boy replied Emil
smiled outwardly but within he couldn't
shake a sense of for boing he stealed
himself for the next question he had to
ask are your parents looking forward to
you Frederick nodded and told the meal
that his parents wanted this to be the
best yiel ever so they made sure to get
a great Yule Log and plenty of delicious
cow milk to drink has anything strange
been happening with the preparations
have you or your parents seen things
Emil asked Frederick paused seemingly
Unsure how to answer Emil quickly
changed the subject you know my wife and
I had the perfect recipe for ginger
cookies no U season is complete without
them perhaps your parents would be
interested in some this may made Fredick
very excited and he agreed to take a
meal to his house for a visit at first
Frederick's parents were concerned about
a visit from the lonely and eccentric
old man Schroeder but in the spirit of
the season they accepted his company
Emil made sure to thank them for their
Hospitality with gifts of ginger cookies
for the first time in several years Emil
schroer was not alone of course this was
not why he had come to visit friedrich's
family there were strange sounds in this
house none loud or unusual enough to not
be mistaken for a creaky floorboard or
an animal on the roof but they were
there Emil wondered to himself if this
would be the night that he would
understand what his life had been
building to he joined the family for a
warm meal by the fire and as they drank
glasses of milk friederick asked to hear
a Ule story with some prodding Emil
offered up a story from the distant past
it was one he had been told as a child
by his own parents the story of a
monster who only came once a year when I
tell you the tale I want you to know
that it was passed down for Generations
in my family all the way back to my
Viking ancestor Vigo the Berserker
Frederick clapped his hands and settled
in to hear Emil's story while his
parents hoped the old man wouldn't tell
something too frightening with that Emil
began weaving the image of an ancient
and storyed Viking long housee he told
it just like his parents told him
describing the many Great and Powerful
Warriors that lived in that Hall among
them of course was a well-honed
Berserker by the name of Vigo for
several nights the Vikings called out to
Odin in Blissful reverence they were so
merry that the signs of strange
wickedness around the long housee went
beneath their notice the wind howled the
roof creaked and the snow was riffed
with bizarre animalistic footsteps and
yet the Vikings partied on in complete
ignorance until the 12th night of fuel
came and there was a fearsome knock at
the door door now this banging came as
quite a surprise to Vikings as all the
people in the area had come to celebrate
Ule in the long housee from the men and
women to the youngest children who could
it be if everyone was already inside
especially as the weather was cold and
damp and the ground was covered in
several feet of snow yet the knocking
had come and it persisted none but vgo
were so bold as to answer the door as he
had the wild strength of the Berserker
in his heart as he undid the the latch
he called out into the blizzard and said
who is so very late to join our Mart we
must offer you a glass of meat he pulled
open the wooden door and through the
crack he saw a face it was unlike any
man he had ever seen before at first he
thought he was looking upon a frozen
corpse bruised and eaten Away by
frostbite but then the gnarled thing
spoke ah the marent has just begun for I
have
arrived in an instant the Torches inside
the long house were blown out with a
howling gust of wind the door was forced
open and the creature entered it was
wire thin but vigorous in movement as a
stag with the strength of a bear with a
small blade in hand it descended upon
the Viking slashing this way and that
the Warriors grabbed their Spears and
axes and tried to fa the creature but
its hide turned away their iron like it
was made out of the very Cliffs Of The
Sea they played with the Vikings and
made sport of snuffing out each of their
lives as the battle turned against them
they realized that there was no escape
nowhere to go but the cold raging storm
that claimed them as much as the
creature Vigo 2o was struck down like
everyone else but his Berserker trans
kept him clinging to this world long
enough to see the strange thing take a
young boy the only Survivor and stuff
him inside of a sack of cloth what are
you Vigo called out unsure if he was in
this world or the next the creature
smiled and replied as long as there are
holy days for thee I too shall be then
the F thing departed in the morning vgo
found himself still alive but forever
shaken Emil bookended the telling by
saying that vgo lived to marry and thus
continue his line down to Emil himself
or so The Story Goes by this point
friederick and his parents were equally
unnerved but Emil simply smiled and made
an offer he was waiting to make for the
whole evening I think I will return your
hospitality now now how about tomorrow
night you all stay at my family home and
we will tell a happier story as Emil
said this his eyes were fixated on the
window out there in the dark was a shape
not unlike a snowman a shape that had
chosen its next Target but perhaps would
need to reconsider for the first time in
almost a hundred years Mary you you Old
Devil it's the holiday season outside
it's cold and there's snow blanketing
the ground but inside your warm and
gathered around the light of a roaring
fireplace and a glowing Christmas tree
this is what Christmas is all about
warmth joy and togetherness but just
because you're comfortable doesn't mean
you're safe you were so busy opening
presents and stuffing yourself at dinner
that you didn't notice the face pressed
up against the window that long gaunt
face with the staring eyes the Wide
Mountain mouth full of yellow teeth and
the scraggly white beard you don't know
it yet but within a few days you'll be
dead you might be able to avert this
horrible fate if you knew what exactly
you were dealing with SCP
4666 also known as the uan a ker class
Christmas monster so violent sadistic
and terrifying he makes Krampus look
like Jolly Saint Nick and this year just
like every other he's planning on being
very very naughty the SCP Foundation
began cataloging the U man in 1974 after
a string of violent and eerily similar
home invasions during the holiday season
but they have reason to believe that
this entity has been around for a whole
lot longer over 2,000 years in fact
stories that describe what looked to be
uan massacres date back as far as the
first century BC in Scandinavia and
there have been reports of similar
clusters of events happening around the
same time every year since this monster
is prolific and may have one of the
highest body counts of any creature
under observation by the foundation the
U man's trail of Destruction became
clearer in the 18th century as accounts
of the Carnage it leaves became more
detailed later still authorities even
managed to find physical evidence like
the U man's fingerprints which are
similar to human fingerprints but
display a distinct double whirl pattern
not seen in human fingerprints much
about the anomalous nature of the U man
is still unknown though and the
foundation has yet to discover an
effective way to contain it their only
hope is intercepting it before it can
get its long gnarled fingers on its
intended prey maybe you're feeling
worried or that you're being watched you
have good reason to be afraid because
during his yearly active period the 12
days between December 21st and January
2nd he's always searching for prey
nowhere is safe because while it was
initially believed that he only appeared
to those who live north of 40° latitude
it's now believed that much like Santa
Claus the uan operates worldwide anyone
could be in his sights right now
blissfully unaware of The Nightmare
coming down the tracks towards them
thankfully the SCP Foundation through
analyst of these attacks which are known
as Vice KN the vents they've been able
to find certain patterns but first what
does the creature known as the uan even
look like much like scp096 the uan is a
long and lanky humanoid standing about 2
m tall who resembles an emaciated human
of European descent and never wears any
clothes or other coverings despite the
frigid temperatures he operates in you
might be sad if you're spending
Christmas alone but it at least
guarantees you safety from the U man as
he only appears at the homes of families
with a child under the age of eight
present he also seems to favor isolated
and Rural locations and vice KN events
only occur when there's a healthy
covering of snow on the ground during
the event hence the name which means
white KN in English it's also vital that
you recognize the three distinct stages
of a vice KN event 2 or you won't be
seeing much of the New Year the first
stage occurs during the space of a week
children in the home might start to seem
worried or afraid they might tell you
that they see something strange in the
distance the figure of a man they don't
recognize standing just far enough away
that you can't fully make him out except
that he's really tall of course you
probably won't see anything and your
instinct will be to tell them there's
nothing to be afraid of even when they
tell you through tears that there's a
man pressing his face up against their
bedroom window at night but they are
right to be afraid and you should be too
already at this point your only hope is
to try and spread the word as soon as
possible report the incident to the
local police write about it on Facebook
tweet about it whatever it takes the SCP
Foundation has operatives trolling the
internet and monitoring police reports
constantly during this period especially
for reports of mysterious men in the
snow watching homes from a distance
getting the foundation's attention is
your best hope of stopping this thing
and if you don't next comes stage two
taking place between kns 8 and 11 of the
active period no longer will The U man
just be lurking on the periphery now now
he's getting closer you'll start to hear
strange noises in your attic or on the
roof noises that sound almost like
footsteps that's crazy you think it's
probably just an animal but then the
smell starts an awful rotten stench that
fills the house but no matter how hard
you look you can't find the source
finally on the last night of December
you'll tell yourself that you'll take
this matter to the police but of course
it's already too late the U man is here
for the 12th night the vice KN is
finally upon you at this point one of
two scenarios will happen in the first
you and your entire family will be
tortured and murdered except the
youngest child who the uan will kidnap
the SCP Foundation keeps files on a
number of notable instances of this kind
of ice knock and the details are truly
gruesome reports of incidents have
involved crucifixion the removal of
tongues burning dismemberment postmortem
B marks and decapitation in all
instances though the entire family was
killed except the youngest child who
simply disappeared the uan is a
merciless and sadistic Beast you're now
probably wondering if that's the first
of two Vice knck possibilities what's
the second in the second if you're
tremendously lucky you and your family
will survive but that doesn't mean you
won't face a Grizzly experience in this
scenario which occurs during about 15%
of ice kned events you'll hear footsteps
throughout the night but thankfully you
wake up alive and when you do so there
are gifts waiting for you the problem is
all these gifts are made out of human
body parts for example in 1976 in Canada
one family received the gift of a ball
made from a severed human head wrapped
in skin in Kazakhstan in 1903 a family
received a flute made from a hollowed
out human femur and in the Netherlands
in 2003 a family received received a
wooden hairbrush covered in human teeth
ranging from 400 years old to a mere few
days these gruesome gifts are referred
to as SCP 4666 daa and it was one of
these gifts that gave us the best
Insight yet available into the true
nature of the uel man several gifts were
dropped off at a family's residence in
Huna Alaska in 2018 but most notably
among them was the horrific SCP
4666 A-
0960 a life-sized doll made from a human
body with its eyes removed and mouth
sewn shut worst of all though was that
the girl was still alive the family who
received this Twisted gift was given a
mi sticks by the foundation and the
living doll was taken for medical
treatment before succumbing to her
extensive injuries the girl was able to
deliver some insights into what exactly
happened to the children who were
abducted during Vice KN events the
children taken by the uan are forced
into a large sack that seems much bigger
on the inside than it appears as he
makes his rounds traveling from house to
house murdering and kidnapping his
victims are taken to a kind of
underground Grotto and workshop filled
with bones like a twisted Santa's
Workshop where they're forced to make
toys out of the bodies of their fellow
victims during this time the Ulan will
continue to torture and torment his
victims he'll even take some of them
away to cook and eat whenever he feels
like it when asked how she was turned
into this human doll the girl told
Foundation Personnel that her fellow
victims were forced to turn her into
this by the uan when she became too weak
to continue making toys herself her
chilling last words were when you can't
make the toys you become the toys so if
strange things happen to you and your
family between the 21st of December and
the 1st of January don't ignore it after
all
you never know who's watching but if it
is the U man's grinning face pressed up
against your window it may already be
too late happy holidays it happened in
1981 in a small rural Village in West
Germany seek guys 9 years old ran across
the bitter snow tears freezing to his
cheeks it was Christmas Day and not long
ago he'd been so happy he was
celebrating with his family his mother
his father and his young sister the
centers of his Universe when that
monster had attacked and destroyed
everything he'd ever known the white
Terror the destroyer of Christmas cheer
the U man SCP
4666 though of course young SE fleed had
no idea in hindsight SE fleet's parents
had been noticing strange things in the
leadup to Christmas Day unfamiliar bumps
and knocks strange smells coming from
the attic the occasional tall dark
silhouette on the horizon outside their
isolated old farmhouse but in all the
hustle and bustle of the Season nobody
really paid the proper attention to all
the signs of an incoming hoist KN event
every Eerie feeling was just written off
as stress or overactive imaginations
none of the Gu Family knew about the
true danger they were facing until they
woke up to to see the uul man standing
over them sharpening a rusty blade and
staring at them with hungry sadistic
eyes Merry
Christmas the creature rasped and
chuckled SED was lucky to escape alive
but of course he would never see his
family again he'd be picked up a day or
so later traumatized catatonic and
almost frozen to death when he was
finally able to speak again he spoke of
a monster having killed his family when
the police investigated at his home and
found the remains they deemed it to be
the work of an all to human serial
killer and poor sik fedge was entered
into the Foster system years of work
with psychiatric professionals tried to
convince young seed that the monster he
claimed to see the unnaturally tall
gnarled bony freak with those shimmering
black eyes was merely a product of his
trauma but he knew the truth he always
knew what he encountered that day the
thing that took his family was nothing
less than a true monster and at 9 years
old Sig fed made a vow he would one day
kill the monster no matter what it took
when Zid was finally adopted and
returned to school he did everything he
could to apply himself academically he
had no interest in friends or romantic
relationships even as he grew into his
teenage years the only thing that Drew
his interest in addition to the
Perfection of his academic life was his
own private Research into the
supernatural he became an expert in all
things occultic and anomalous sightings
of ghosts Phantoms aliens and monsters
he wanted to know it all no needed to
know it all he would arm himself with
knowledge wanting to know everything he
could in advance of the confrontation
that would be his final Destiny he also
began obsessively researching attacks
similar to the ones that killed his
family and found an eerie pattern
seemingly to unfold all over the
Northern Hemisphere during the 12 Days
of Christmas entire families would be
found dead in their homes mutilated
horrifically often with children having
gone completely missing they happened
far enough apart in terms of time and
space that no connection was drawn
between the events all just random
attacks according to the police and
media weren't the connections obvious he
didn't understand it it was almost like
there was some kind of sweeping cover up
obscuring the true culprit behind all
these killings the same Beast that
destroyed his life as Sig freed now
known to most as Dr G ascended through
his time at University he became one of
Germany's foremost Scholars on the
occult with several published papers and
books that Drew fascination of fellow
experts and laymen alike but most
importantly of all seek Freed's work got
the attention of the SCP Foundation they
reached out to the ambitious rising star
of the Paranormal world and offered him
a res SE Arch position Dr G was elated
and said that he would happily take the
role if they answered one question for
him did they know anything about a
horrific humanoid monster that attacked
families across the Northern Hemisphere
around Christmas time this was the
moment when Dr SEF G after Decades of
searching finally came to know about SCP
4666 he had access to all the SCP
foundation's information on the monster
putting him several steps closer to what
had always been his ultimate goal
killing that godforsaken thing but this
would be easier said than done after all
if the uan was easy to track the
foundation would have captured and
contained him long before now his
attacks could occur anywhere across the
Northern Hemisphere making catching him
the world's largest game of whack-a-mole
but this was a game that Dr G had more
than enough patience to play over The
Following years Dr G worked as as hard
as humanly possible not just at the case
of SCP
4666 but at every piece of work the
foundation had to offer him much like
his ruined childhood guys made no effort
to interact no effort to form social
connections he just worked and worked
and worked and worked with single-minded
passion soon developing a reputation as
one of the most hardworking and
dependable figures in the SCP
foundation's European division it was
this kind of work ethic that soon saw
him promoted to senior researcher and
then a site director he had more control
over information resources and Manpower
than ever before it was almost time he
could sense it delegating other tasks to
his subordinates Dr G began to work on
his Masterpiece an advanced algorithm
connecting police social media and
surveillance databases across the
Northern Hemisphere you see while Dr G
had never fall altered in his quest
neither had the uul man every year more
families disappeared or were
horrifically murdered and every death
weighed on guys he saw them as a
personal failing of his of his inability
to fulfill his Destiny but the Ulan was
a creature of habit and it would be that
very adherence to Habit that guys used
to destroy it using the algorithm he
created they would perfectly track and
triangulate the home most likely to be
the subject of a dreaded whn the EV with
greater accuracy and precision than ever
before the year was 2022 Dr G was
convinced that this time he would be the
one to claim victory and Vengeance there
was one thing he didn't tell his
foundation compatriots though as he put
the pieces in place for the final
showdown he had no intention of
containing the U man this time he would
destroy it using his Newfound influence
as a well-respected site director he
requested the transfer of a a few
high-profile anomalies as well as the
services of a crack mobile task force
death squad it was time the ulman
watched the house from a distance he'd
been observing for days watching the
nice happy family within what pleasure
it would bring him to destroy them and
take what's left to his workshop for
further fun tonight would be the night
that he claimed them they were all
blissfully unaware and lived in an
isolated rural area where nobody but him
would hear all the one wonderful
screaming the second the lights went out
inside the house he would strike and
bring about some Christmas fear when the
last window went dark the uan drew a
long Rusty blade out of his bag of
tricks and approached the house he crept
in through one of the windows locks had
never been a problem for him this whole
process had played out hundreds of times
he barely even needed to think about it
now he crept in past the presents around
the Christmas tree found the stairs and
began to climb he'd find them in their
beds one by one and take his time
savoring the pain savoring the fear he
went into the youngest one's bedroom
first his lips pulled back into a manic
grin there was the little boy tucked in
under his quilt like a present waiting
to be unwrapped he grabbed the sheet
with his long gnarled fingers and pulled
it back only to see a plastic dummy
underneath with a stun grenade fixed to
its chest before the uan could even
react the stun grenade exploded into his
face blinding him with a sudden white
light and ringing in his ancient ears
the next thing ye heard was a rugged
military voice yelling Squad Alpha move
in seconds later the upstairs Landing
was filled with mobile task force
operatives with assault rifles they
aimed an open fire into the uan
peppering him with painful bullets he
wasn't used to his victims fighting back
like this truthfully it even caught him
off guard but sadly for those Brave task
force opport
it would not be enough to kill him the
uan gripped his Rusty knife and lunched
at Squad Alpha moments later they were
all dead and the Furious uan was
trudging back down the stairs there had
been no satisfaction in this Slaughter
how had they caught him like this
perhaps he'd go eat some of his servants
in his Workshop to make himself feel
better as he walked back across the
living room past the Christmas tree past
all the presents the television
flickered into life staring at him from
the screen was the grinning face of Dr
SED G Now 50 years old and the most
insane part was that the U man somehow
recognized him the one who got away 41
years prior hello old friend you're
looking a little Glam Sig freed said on
the screen I take it that you did not
enjoy the surprise party I just threw
for you don't worry the night isn't over
yet after all you haven't even opened
your presents with that the presents
under the tree which were actually
packed with C4 plastic explosives
detonated leveling the entire house with
the uan still inside the explosion could
be heard for Miles as a great pillar of
smoke rose up into the air several
hundred meters away Dr seed3 guys waited
and watched flanked by Foundation agents
and more mobile task force soldiers
taking in the Majesty of the explosion
Dr G remained steel eyed and watched The
Blaze somehow he knew that even that
would not be enough to end the monster
permanently he nodded to the lieutenant
he' brought with him Squad out Squad
Bravo time to engage the man barked in
response the remaining agents and MTF
operatives armed with assault rifles and
submachine guns descended on the burning
wreckage of the house moments later a
tall dark figure the uan injured but
alive crawled out of the blaze
immediately the team opened fire giving
the monster everything they had but once
again everything was not enough the
creature pulled out two long Rusty
knives and leaped Into The Fray making
short work of the foundation brass soon
enough it stood alone on Blood Stained
snow until it caught another bullet in
the head Dr seed three guys was standing
there The Last One Alive to face the uan
leveling a revolver the uan scalled guys
held his steel gaze we meet again at
long last Sig freed said you killed my
family you've killed so many others
tonight it is your turn UL man this is
your WN Guys open fire as the uan
charged towards him taking each shot in
stride even as the uan closed the
distance guys didn't Flinch his resolve
was Steely it made the U man feel
confused and Furious that he didn't
detect an ounce of fear in this man even
when he drove a knife into the site
director's stomach seek freed dropped to
his knees and collapsed as the Ulan
ripped the knife back out his gun
clattered to the ground it had been a
mortal blow and still he seemed unfazed
why aren't you afraid the U man growled
Sig freed spat blood and said you took
my family 41 years ago everything since
then has just been killing time until I
got to see them
again where you're going all you'll ever
see are flames and torment the Yu man
Furious stabbed Sig freed again this
time through the heart the doctor was
dying his life's work having seemingly
amounted to nothing but with the last of
his strength he reached into his coat
and pulled out something a little gift
he' requested from one Dr Alto cleff
before putting his plan into action Dr
seek feed guys lifted a photo of scp096
right in front of the Ule Man's eyes
Mary
Christmas he said with his last breath
the uan was confused a photograph was
that it was that really this foolish
little boy's trump card after all this
time what a waste then without a
moment's warning scp096 barreled into
the uan sending them both rolling across
the snow one of Sig Freed's preparations
was to have SC scp096 is containment
Cube temporarily relocated to only a
mile away from the Ambush site to avoid
collateral damage if everything else
failed then scp096 would be their Hail
marry pass their finishing move and it
worked marvelously as strong and evil as
the U man was he'd been weakened by the
night's battle and the shy guy was an
order of magnitude more powerful than
his sadistic foe the uan screamed in
horror as scp096 set upon him with claws
and teeth after hundreds of years
inflicting it on others the uan had died
in Terror and Dr seek plate guys had
died with a smile on his face Christmas
some know it as the Most Wonderful Time
of the Year a time for snow hot
chocolate family and a sense of magic in
the air others know it as a time of
stress last minute shopping canceled
flights and relatives you'd rather not
be stuck in a room with no matter how
you feel about Christmas there's one
thing thing we can all agree on it only
comes once a year right well that might
be true in most of the world but the SCP
Foundation came across one particular
little town where the Christmas party
never stops For Better or For much much
worse SCP 784 is a neighborhood in a
small Texas town made up of 24 houses
and two apartment buildings every last
one of them is decorated top to bottom
in bright twinkling Christmas lights no
matter how hot it is outside and Texas
Summers can be brutal the ground is
always blanketed with at least 12 cm of
snow curiously there is never any
visible snowfall happening in the
neighborhood that would explain this the
snow is just always there it might look
inviting from the outside a quaint
little neighborhood where the snow never
melts and the Christmas lights never go
out but the folks at the SCP Foundation
know by now that things are rarely ever
what they seem all of the houses in SCP
784 are occupied by beings referred to
as SCP
784-1000 people living in SCP 784 and
they appear to age like normal people
though no deaths of
scp-784-1 have ever been observed the
citizens of SCP 784 for spend their time
doing activities exclusively associated
with Christmas and the holiday season
they sing Christmas carols perform
Christmas pageants throw eggnog
festivals give gifts and decorate their
homes when the Sun goes down the
activities turned to acts of Christmas
themed vandalism decorating any object
or living thing deemed not cheerful
Enough by any means necessary when a
foundation Supply Convoy stopped near
SCP 784 for the night in order to refuel
they got to experience this maniacal
dedication to the Christmas spirit
firsthand first the foundation Vehicles
were egged drawing the attention of the
Personnel on board as the foundation
operatives chased off the egg based
asants they left several Vehicles
unattended when they returned they found
their vehicles and Equipment changed
into something a bit more festive first
they noticed that a Humvee had been
converted into a sleigh then upon
checking the inventory of a weapon
weapon shipment on board they realized
the fragmentation grenades had been
replaced with glass Christmas ornaments
and antlers had been welded on to the
156 safety helmets in their possession
unsettled by these changes and the speed
at which the seemingly human instances
of
scp-784-1 had been able to make them the
Personnel attempted to drive away when
they started their engines they were
shocked at a loud sputtering sound and
bursts of nutmeg scented smoke while
they were gone their fuel tanks had been
filled with eggnog if this encounter
wasn't enough to demonstrate that SCP
784 was not to be trifled with there
were several incidents of SCP Foundation
agents entering the bounds of the
neighborhood and failing to adequately
perform the required Christmas
celebrations when someone's Christmas
cheer is not up to par instances of
scp-784-1 in the vicinity respond
immediately and aggressively
incapacitating the offending person and
forcing them into the nearest house five
different Foundation agents have been
abducted in this way so far the First
Foundation agent to be abducted was
agent Paulson while patrolling through
SCP 784 dressed in a Rudolph the
Red-nose Reindeer sweater and a Santa
hat agent Paulson made the grave mistake
of wishing a passing person happy
holidays in the blink of an eye the mood
around her darken eight stone-faced
people with their Holly Jolly attire
surrounded agent Paulson she attempted
to draw her weapon to defend herself but
simply was not fast enough thrashing and
screaming for help agent pson was
dragged into a nearby Home kicking over
an inflatable Snowman on the way in next
agent Matthews was on night Patrol when
a bout of spontaneous carolling broke
out he joined in singing Silent Night in
an attempt to blend in with the
instances of
scp-784-1
unfortunately he misremembered the
lyrics to the song and began singing the
third verse while everyone else was on
the second while still singing the
citizens overwhelmed agent Matthews and
tied him up with a string of decorative
red and green lights agent Sanderson who
was supervising the Patrol attempted to
intervene and free Matthews which
attracted the attention of more
instances of
scp-784-1 both agents were overwhelmed
by the crowd restrained and pulled into
a home for what can only be described as
Christmas Carol reprogramming observers
heard the sound of Christmas carols
being sung inside for several days after
while on his Patrol agent Anderson
tripped and stubbed his toe hard against
a Santa Claus themed lawn gnome
overwhelmed by pain and irritation
Anderson swore loudly and violently for
a duration of 14 seconds at the sound of
his salty language three instances of
scp-784-1 sprang into action and grabbed
Anderson before he could react two held
his body in place restraining his arms
and forcing foring him to his knees the
third held his head still tilting it
back and forcing his mouth open a fourth
instance emerged from a house carrying a
court of eggnog as Anderson struggled to
no avail the eggnog was poured into his
mouth until the court was empty and he
collapsed limply on the ground once he
was rendered unconscious the instances
of
scp-784-1 dragged him inside finally
agent Davids was observing the
neighborhood when he was offered a
present by one of the few children in
the town a young girl wearing a sparkly
green and red sweater and a headband
decorated with reindeer antlers Davids
accepted the gift with a forced smile
and thanked the little girl but
apparently did not respond with enough
enthusiasm when he failed to give the
reaction she was looking for the little
girl tackled him with a surprising
amount of force grabbing him around his
legs and knocking him to the ground
before he could regain his balance and
climb to his feet several more children
emerged from a nearby house and dragged
David's inside pulling him by his arms
and legs between 1 and 3 days after they
were taken the abducted Personnel
emerged from the house they were pulled
into they were all dressed in new more
elaborate Christmas wear from light up
sweaters to headbands covered in tiny
presents when a supervisor attempted to
extract the foundation Personnel the
Personnel refused to leave when the
issue was pressed further the instances
of scp-784-1 around them became
increasingly aggressive and even violent
in their attempt to protect the abducted
agent Paulson Matthews Anderson
Sanderson and Davids are still within
the boundaries of SCP 784 and are all
considered lost the official story is
that they died in the line of duty in
order to protect their families from the
truth SCP 784 d1's fixation on Christmas
spirit doesn't only extend to humans and
inanimate objects and any living being
within the walls of SCP 784 that doesn't
look festive enough is subject to a
swarm of citizens decorating it and that
includes animals during several patrols
Foundation Personnel have observed 15
Stray Cats given Red collars with a
small bell seven stray dogs adorned with
reindeer antlers rabbits and raccoons
with Santa hats forced onto their heads
and even deer dressed up to resemble the
iconic Rudolph out of an abundance of
caution and in an attempt to prevent any
future abductions there have been
extreme limits placed on the number of
Staff allowed to patrol inside of SCP
784 the foundation currently only sends
in agents under special circumstances
most notably for a regular occurrence
known as a noell event about once a
month instances of SCP 7841 will attempt
to exit the boundaries of SCP 784 and
enter a nearby neighborhood in the
suburban community that surrounds 784
each member of the community carries a
15m long string of Christmas lights and
they wander in a group until they have
found an undecorated house they will
begin to promptly decorate this house
winding the Christmas lights around it
until it looks identical to the rest of
the houses in SCP 784 it is unclear what
happens to the residents of the chosen
house but it is likely that they are
converted into SCP
7841 much like the abducted Foundation
agents naturally the foundation has has
a vested interest in preventing SCP 784
from expanding and is dedicated to
tracking and preventing these Noel
events Noel events do not happen on an
exact schedule but the foundation has
become aware of certain warning signs
that one may be coming prior to a Noel
event SCP 7841 becomes more actively
festive during the day notably
increasing their singing decorating and
eggnog consumption when these signs have
been noted a select team of personnel is
ordered ordered to execute procedure
784-8487 they sing the classic Carol
good King Wess and pass out
non-alcoholic eggnog to the other
Personnel stationed with them naturally
this draws the attention of
scp-784-1 unable to resist the Allure of
holiday cheer and Goodwill towards men
once they have arrived the Personnel
distribute a secondary batch of eggnog
to
scp-784-1 this one mixed with a mild
sedative after the drugg to eggnog has
been passed out the foundation Personnel
are to sing carols with the citizens of
SCP 784 as the sedative takes effect as
instances of SCP 784 D1 begin to pass
out their neighbors will silently carry
them into their designated homes on
their own own until all of them have
fallen asleep if procedure
released to the public in order to
prevent civilians from accidentally
happening upon SCP 784 the neighborhood
has been disguised as an ordinary gated
community it is surrounded by a 3.5 M
High 0.8 M thick concrete wall topped
with an electrified steel cable the
foundation is not allowed to prevent
non-foundation Personnel from entering
in order to mitigate the risk of a
violent reaction from
scp-784-1 however when an individual not
related to the foundation is spot
spotted leaving the neighborhood they
are to be swiftly detained interrogated
and given an amnestic no Foundation
Personnel are permitted to enter the
neighborhood unless they are dressed in
Christmas attire these personnel must
also be armed with a knowledge of all
basic Christmas carols the area is to be
monitored at all times via Foundation
owned weather balloon and the citizens
of SCP 784 are to be watched for unusual
behavior and the signs of an impending
Noel event SCP 784 is currently
classified as uid and is considered to
be largely non-threatening as long as it
continues to be contained the citizens
of SCP 784 are not overtly harming
anyone and they don't seem to want
anything more than to celebrate
Christmas forever however it's UNC how
far they would attempt to expand if Noel
events were allowed to occur with no
intervention perhaps they would expand
forever forcing eggnog down throats and
strangling houses with twinkling lights
turning the world as we know it into a
twisted snow globe hopefully we'll never
have to find out just be careful if
you're wandering through the suburbs of
Texas and hear the jingling of sleigh
bells in July or you might find yourself
on SCP 784 naughty
list merry Christmas happy holidays and
freaky Festivus to you all from your
good friends at SCP explained deck the
halls with bowels of SCP 47 induced
plant life because today we're going to
hit you with the kind of Christmas cheer
you just can't contain hang your
stockings pour a tall glass of eggnog
and slip on your most hideous U tied
sweater because this is a ker kind of
Christmas we've discussed Christmas
anomalies both in depth and in passing
on this channel before like SCP
4666 the positively terrifying uan whose
ritual Christmas time slayings strike
fear into the hearts of families
everywhere or as CP 784 Christmas cheer
a community where it's Christmas every
day and anyone who refuses to show the
proper spirit is dragged off and given a
forcible re-education in the reason for
the season there's even the pitiful SCP
1933 a fat sweaty and perpetually drunk
middle-aged man in a Santa suit who has
Irish cream for blood reminds me of my
Uncle Frank but today we're dealing with
something really special a Christmas
variety show hosted by everyone's
favorite anomalous Foundation researcher
SCP
963 sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
we mean Dr brigh Dr brigh is getting
ready to receive guests for his
Christmas party like no other and the
good news is we're all invited there's
going to be stories songs comedy and
more cameos than you could shake a uog
at so get comfortable it's going to be a
fun one but first a quick mess message
from this episode's sponsors the fine
folks at the shark punching Center the
first and last line of defense between
us and those dark-eyed subaquatic
menaces and of course the latest giggle
tastic product from our good pals at the
Dr wondertainment toy company a perfect
stocking filler for the Christmas season
that's right we're talking about spider
party just Add Water for 880,000 legs
worth of arach no Funia warning parental
supervision required your definition of
arachn Funia May differ from that used
by Dr Wonder tainment avoid use of this
product if you're sensitive to spider
venom not for use in households with pet
or which are situated on reclaimed toxic
waste dumps and or Indian burial grounds
doctor entertainment is not responsible
for any cases of spider itis spyer rois
or spider Mania caused by use of this
product not to be used for gambling
purposes without the express written
consent of Dr W tainment oh and of
course an additional thank you to our
friends at the Mana charitable
foundation for their generous Grant more
on that one later while Dr Bry prepared
for guests SCP 1845 a collection of
freakishly intelligent animals including
a raccoon a crow a baby Pig a chicken
and a fox by the name of King Eugenio
prepared a dress rehearsal for a
nativity scene conflict erupted when the
chicken kept flubbing her lines and the
other cast members found it strange that
King Eugenio insisted on playing the
baby Jesus himself by all accounts he
was kind of a nightmare to work with
thanks to his massive ego the situation
worsened when SCP 329 j a floating yield
sign that believes it's a ghost turned
up claiming to be the Ghost of Christmas
Past and started bothering King Eugenio
if you think this is weird you're going
to have real trouble with the rest of
this so we recommend sitting back
putting your feet up and just rolling
with it cuz it's only going to get
stranger from here anyway back to the
living room of Dr Jack brigh who was
singing a special SCP Foundation parody
of the Christmas carol God Rest Ye Merry
Gentlemen when the first set of guests
arrive it was Dr Charles odden gears a
famously humorless Foundation senior
researcher dressed in his own adorably
God Christmas attire but he wasn't alone
he' brought special musical guests
Captain and tennial the classic 1970s
Duo responsible for hits such as Love
Will Keep Us Together and Muskrat Love
they'd actually attended gigs like this
before but thanks to the beauty of Class
A amnestics it was all new to them Let's
ignore the murky ethical implications of
that and keep on trucking next this
Christmas Extravaganza cared into
another anomalous skit this one
featuring SCP 119 to a little boy named
Timmy who was somehow transformed into a
bird and count rockula a badass heavy
metal officient Auto summoned by SCP
1987 J's anomalously sick cord
progression Timmy was naturally a little
upset about being trapped as a bird and
thus he was unable to spend Christmas
with his family count rockula being the
Lord of ultimate rockness refused to let
the poor bird boy suffer in order to
cheer him up he grabbed his guitar and
launched into a spirited rock and roll
Christmas Carol with much racer lyrics
than you'd probably expect from a
wholesome Christmas tune the count was
left feeling a little nervous afterwards
when Timmy started asking him what
a camel toe was the sooner we get away
from this little disaster of a segment
the better back to Dr Bright's living
room once more the good anomalous doctor
had just finished telling a hilarious
anecdote to Dr gears and 1970s music
Powerhouse Captain N tennial when Dr
gears took the opportunity to break some
bad news a certain very Rowdy former
party guest had found out about this
year's Meetup and he would likely be
joining any minute now much to Bright's
dismay as if On Queue the door burst
open and there stood SCP
076-2 also known as AEL The Immortal
swordsman wearing an ugly Christmas
sweater and a Santa hat yelling did
somebody say
party Dr brght was Mor IED at last
year's party Abel had gotten tanked on
hard eggnog and embarrassed them all in
front of country music legend Willie
Nelson with his Antics specifically he'd
stolen a local sleigh and used it to run
over Bright's grandmother hilarious
however Abel insisted that this time
around he'd be well behaved only time
would tell if that prediction held any
water he began to sing a personalized
parody of Away in a Manger in a grading
falsetto voice as an act of penance
let's get away from those goofballs
again and hop over to another Ace
comedic Duo Lord Blackwood and
Wellington G Wonder Horse Blackwood also
known as SCP 1867 is a telepathic sea
slug who believes he was once a
gallivanting British noble and Explorer
and Wellington also known as SCP 1156 is
a talking horse with a thick Cockney
accent and a Dapper Woolen scarf and Top
Hat this pair of talking creatures wish
the audience a very Merry Christmas
before engaging in conversation however
this didn't get very far as Lord
Blackwood couldn't understand
Wellington's thick Cockney accent when
Lord Blackwood got too frustrated to go
on he called Wellington a horse's ass
everybody laughs roll on snare drums
curtains now then back to Dr Brit's
increasingly chaotic Christmas house
party Abel was already getting a little
slashed and telling wild jokes when
another guest appeared at the door when
Dr brigh answered he saw Dr wries a
female fellow researcher standing there
in a full body trench coat she expressed
a desire to meet Dr brigh under the
mistletoe to which she replied rites I I
didn't put up any mistletoe this year
but rites obviously in the Christmas
spirit with a smile on her face and with
no concern for the lack of mistletoe at
the party disroe from her trench coat
dawned in her hand knitted wool
Christmas two-piece she began to dance
towards Dr bright while singing a parody
of the Saucy Christmas hit Santa uh baby
okay um let's cut to another word from
one of our sponsors the wonderful Folks
at the Mana charitable Foundation the
world's leading anomalous charity group
in this sponsorship break Mana
charitable Foundation representative
Sally struther placed a small mechanical
Contraption on the table and said this
is the Christmas miracle maker thanks to
state-of-the-art terraforming technology
this durable and easytouse device once
activated will induce rapid and
aggressive climate change in order to
transform its surrounding environment
into a perfect snowy Winter's day just
in time for a White Christmas the seed
banks and genetic samples contained
within it will ensure that Majestic
Evergreens just right for decorating and
reindeer perfect for pulling a oneor
open sleigh will replace all the local
flora and fauna and it can even whip up
a Christmas dinner with all the
trimmings for those souls in need every
one of your donations puts us one step
closer to our goal of manufacturing and
airdropping 15,000 of these units across
Africa in time for Christmas Eve so
please call in your pledge or write a
check today and let them know it's
Christmas time again thank you Sally
let's get back to Dr Bright's party now
things are looking a little more safe
for work if only slightly at least
decorated Russian mobile task force
operative agent strelnikov had joined
the party and was naturally beginning to
make multiple jokes about how much he
hates chins much to the discomfort of
everyone else in attendance the other
party guests tried to make him discuss
literally anything else but he refused
repeatedly circling back to telling
stories about chin he only broke from
his diet tribe to give a rendition of
the formerly popular Trololo meme song
which he insisted was a traditional
Russian song of homecoming back to King
Eugenio the fox who' been going through
a parallel Christmas Carol narrative
this whole time during Dr Bright's story
The Talking yield sign was his Spirit of
Christmas Past and while we sadly missed
his Spirit of Christmas present as we
join him before his own gravestone we
can see that his Spirit of Christmas Yet
to Come was SCP
173 the sculpture as the sculpture
pointed towards King eugenio's Grave in
judgmental silence Eugenio came to terms
with what a jerk he'd been when he was
freed from this horrible fantasy he
realized that he needed to change his
ways and thankfully there was still time
back to Dr Brit's Christmas party which
was in full swing however Captain nenni
who had been in charge of cooking the
Christmas goose had made a terrible
mistake they were told to run it through
SCP 9914 on the fine setting which would
create a wonderful Goose roast but
instead they ran it through the very
fine mode turning it into a collection
of live goslings however in their
greatest hour of need a hero Rose Dr
clef appeared at the door dressed as
Santa Claus with enough delicious clam
chowder for everyone and as the party
guests enjoyed their chowder even more
guests arrived King Eugenio Wellington
SCP 173 Lord Blackwood the ghostly yield
sign count rockula Timmy the bird and
even Sally Struthers while the rest of
the anomalous animals formed a perfect
nativity scene while count rockula
performed a rock and roll rendition of
Come All Ye Faithful Dr brigh was
content that everyone here had learned
the true meaning of Christmas after all
even King Eugenio had learned a lot
about being more kind and compassionate
to his fellow beasts with the help of
Lord Blackwood he obtained
cp662 the butler's handbell and used it
to summon Mr Deeds along with a
delicious fully cooked Christmas goose
with all the trimmings while Dr wries
flirted with Abel and the other party
guests prepared to enjoy their chowder
and Goose Dr brigh wished everyone a
happy Christmas with Timmy adding and
343 bless us everyone we helped this
little exploration into how the
foundation celebrates Christmas has
helped your heart grow three sizes this
day and not in the way it would if you
ate a meal off of SCP 807 stay tuned for
a ker kind of Hanukkah and a ker kind of
K Quanza coming soon think back to your
childhood and ask yourself what was the
most pain you've ever felt while growing
up as we develop our understanding of
pain evolves according to our different
experiences the older we get the
injuries we suffered as children like a
scraped knee or a bee sting rarely caus
us the same level of distress as they
used to of course course when you are
young and unfamiliar with sensations of
pain what you really need in that moment
straight after you've fallen off your
bike or tripped playing soccer is
someone to pick you back up and give
your Source spot a kiss perhaps you even
need a bowl of warm soup to comfort you
luckily for you SCP 348 is exactly that
while many of the anomalies held in
containment by the SCP Foundation have
earned the uid or inFAMOUS ker class
designations SCP 348 is is one of the
few considered to be safe both in the
sense it poses no containment risk and
in that it wouldn't hurt a fly it is
neither an ancient eldrich Abomination
From Another Dimension spreading its
influence in our world through mimetic
stimuli nor is it a recording of a
basketball game in which all the players
and Spectators are trapped inside it
isn't an indestructible limb generating
reptile or a towering winged being
wielding a flaming sword and guarding
the entrance to the Garden of Eden to
put it simp L SCP 348 is a bowl a white
ceramic Bowl the kind you would find
almost anywhere in the world it may even
look indistinguishable from the one in
your kitchen cabinet of course SCP 348
is hardly as ordinary as it outwardly
appears to be and it certainly isn't the
only inanimate object that the
foundation keeps safely stored away the
key thing that differentiates SCP 348
from most other anomalies is how
genuinely harmless it is it's anomal
less properties do not cause injury to
any individual that interacts with it
nor does this bowl have any adverse
effects on the world around it SCP 348
cannot bend or reshape reality it does
not cause the person eating from it to
have premonitions of their own death and
using it certainly does not manifest a
contract making entity at the opposite
side of the table so what makes this
bowl in any way anomalous what about it
categorizes it as an SCP and not just a
harmless piece of fine crocod
well why don't we start with how SCP 348
was first discovered some time ago the
SCP Foundation was made aware of rumors
surrounding the child living in an
unknown part of the world according to
the intelligence gathered by the
foundation this child seemed to possess
some sort of healing ability or at least
this is what rumors suggested upon
further investigation the source of
these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared
to come from a small ceramic pole which
we now know as SCP 348 this is not to
say that the bowl has any inherently
Supernatural healing properties and it
doesn't impart any regenerative power to
those that eat from it either it does
heal in a certain sense but not in the
way you're probably imagining when the
SCP Foundation recovered SCP 348 there
were no markings on it indicating where
the bowl came from or who it was
manufactured by the only visually
distinct details worthy of note were
flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand painted around both the inside and
outside of SCP 348 the ceramic surface
also bore the Chinese letters Shang
shini which translates to the phrase
thinking of you the child that first
discovered it found the ceramic Bowl in
the Attic of their home the child's
parents were both full-time workers and
seemed to be somewhat neglectful of
their child although they refused to
comment on this but according to the
findings of the SCP Foundation the child
had come to rely on SCP through 348
deciding to further investigate the
anomalous properties of SCP 348 the
foundation began testing it given that
the child who first discovered the bow
had relied upon it tests involve
Foundation researchers presenting
certain children to SCP 348 and
observing the results so was this bowl
haunted perhaps harboring some malicious
Spirit or entity that sought to corrupt
these children maybe even healing them
in order to somehow use them as a vessel
to break into our world no and while it
may have not healed in any overt or
expected way it did heal in at least a
metaphorical sense if presented with an
injured child sporting any form of minor
ailment such as a cut or a running nose
SCP 348 fills with warm soup and yes
that's right we said soup what kind you
may ask well that seems to vary
sometimes it is tomato soup other times
it might be chicken noodle soup while
the ingredients used in the soups are
often different the there are notable
consistencies to our SCP 348 heels if
anyone between the ages of 4 years old
and 18 years old sits down in front of
the blue flowered Bowl then SCP 348 will
fill with soup numerous young test
subjects brought in by the foundation to
eat from this particular bowl of soup
have reported that they enjoyed their
meal usually finishing the entire Bowl
when permitted to by research staff many
of the injured children that were tested
have stated that the soup they eat from
SCP 348 reminds them of their parents
cooking these children have expressed
contentment and feelings of comfort
after acquiring their various cuts and
bruises some even claimed that even
though they were in a room all alone
they didn't feel lonely when they were
eating the soup and all the anomalous
properties don't end after a child
finishes the soup usually although not
always the bowl will leave the child a
message often some brief words of
reassurance or Comfort these messages
materialize on the inside rim of the
bowl and seem to be specifically
tailored to the subject that is just
eaten the words will not only be written
in the child's first language but are
often linked to the child's home life or
relationship with their parents messages
that appear on SCP 348 usually fade over
time normally disappearing after a few
hours or when the bowl refills with more
soup one test of SCP 348 saw a little
girl age8 and suffering from a sore
throat brought before the bowl according
to a back screening made by research
Personnel the girl lived with her
biological parents and apparently had a
good relationship with both her mother
and her father when SCP 348 filled with
soup for her the girl took almost half
an hour to finish eating and afterwards
reported that she felt her sore throat
get better as she ain't by the end of
the meal this test subject remarked that
she felt completely normal in this
instance no message appeared within the
bowl another child was brought in to
continue the testing of SCP 348 this
time a boy of 10 unlike the previous
test this boy was not on good terms with
his parents and often argued with them
at the time of testing the boy had
sustained several minor bruises the
result of a small accident that occurred
while the boy had been out riding his
bike much like the little girl this
subject ate the soup that SCP 348
presented him with this time though the
bowl offered a message to the boy the
lettering found on the ceramic surface
of SCP 348 simply read don't forget to
brush messages also appeared when an
11-year-old boy with a slight cold ate
soup from the bowl this child had been
adopted by a foster family and after
eating from SCP 348 he saw the message
I'm glad you're happy appear another
young test subject a boy age six had a
similar experience in this instance the
child had several scrapes and scratches
from playing with his friends his
parents had divorced and he was living
with his mother at the time of Tes ing
this time SCP 348 message to this boy
read I'm sorry son a 7-year-old girl
suffering from a cough was brought in
before SCP 348 she had lost her father
to a traffic accident some time before
testing commenced and receive the
message I love you after finishing her
soup further testing conducted by the
foundation revealed that anyone over the
age of 18 years who attempted to eat
soup from SCP 348 experienced things
slightly differently unlike the children
older subjects mostly displayed a
disinterest in finishing their meal a
common complaint among those over 18 was
that the soup was missing something
however in a few isolated cases testing
SCP 348 on older candidates still
revealed messages although the words
seemed to be faded not the clear handp
painted blue that appeared when the
children had finished their soup one
woman aged 30 who was suffering from a
headache sat down in front of SCP 348
much like it had done before the bowl
filled with soup and the woman ate as
with some of the younger subjects a key
aspect of This Woman's background seemed
to be what triggered the message to
appear specifically she admitted to
being on bad terms with her mother and
father the woman explained that she had
opted to live on her own isolating
herself from her family in fact she even
described having rejected an offer her
father made to her many years earlier
refusing some Career Training that he
was willing to give in order to help her
secure a job when she finish the soup
one word appeared in the bowl why
another woman who was 40 years old was
also brought in for the SCP 348 testing
much like the previous subject she had
moved away from home and became arange
from her parents over the years but
unlike the previous test this woman had
taken it upon herself to not only send
money to her parents but also arranged
senior care for both as well prior to
testing her father had died peacefully
of natural causes after spending his
last days in the care that the this
woman had paid for as the woman ate the
soup from the bowl she remarked about
its apparently bitter taste but also
described her meal as fulfilling after
she had finished the words thank you
appeared with an SCP 348 one other adult
subject that produced a noticeable
result from SCP 348 was a 40-year-old
male the results of this test appeared
to be the most distinctly different from
any previous adult or Child by now
researchers working for the SCP
Foundation had determined that familial
history seemed to play an important role
in the outcome of any interaction with
SCP 348 and this individual was
certainly different to most the man in
question had murdered his father roughly
a year before the testing took place he
began the test with SCP 348 while
Afflicted with aches in his back after
one Taste of the soup that appeared in
the Bowl before him the murderer was
immediately repulsed he complained about
the taste refusing to eat any more from
SC CP 348 shortly after the man began to
experience severe stomach pain the
potentially poisonous soup was disposed
of but SCP 348 immediately filled with
saltwater which took 3 hours to
disappear from the bowl despite
conducting numerous tests with subjects
of all ages and ailments the SCP
Foundation researchers have so far been
unable to determine the origins of the
messages that sometimes appear in SCP
348 some are theorize because of the
family histories of some children and
adults tested that the words somehow
come from the father of whoever eats the
soup since even when a subject's father
is alive or present in their life the
message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other
researchers claim that this is just the
purpose of SCP 348 to provide Comfort to
small children dealing with pain both
inside and out after all isn't providing
Comfort what a good bowl of soup
anomalous or not is best at the tiny
carnivorous snowmen are Relentless sharp
fangs dripping with blood as they crawl
on mass towards the mobile task force
opening fire on them with their assault
rifles who would have guessed that a
mere hour or too earlier a young boy was
joyfully playing around in the snow here
how had things gone from Frosty to
freaky so fast let's rewind the clock
there was a chill in the air that
lingering biting cold would NW in your
Exposed Skin if you dared to step
outside in anything less than a thick
warm coat for protection the ground was
still coated in a heavy snowfall a
holdover from Christmas just past
weather that had refused to let up well
into the early days of the New Year
everyone reaches an age where the
cynicism of Life the weight of
expectations that keep you anchored in
the real world they all coales to rob
you of the childlike wonder of the snow
as you get older the snow loses its
number novelty it becomes a source of
inconvenience something that you need to
shovel off the driveway to take your car
out whereas turn the clock back to Youth
and it's like a tiny Miracle It Coats
your whole world in a clean blanket of
freezing Frost turning the ordinary into
a Wonderland Robert and Michaela
Anderson were glad that their son
Michael was still at an age where he
could enjoy the snow after all Michaela
getting to take her son out in the sled
or see seeing him hurling snowballs at
Robert was able to provide them with a
little bit of warmth during the freezing
cold snowier months in Missouri optimism
was never enough to melt the snow
however and maybe that's what drew in
those creatures the snowmen it was early
2019 not even a full 2 weeks into the
Year by now Michael had gotten used to
the fact that after Christmas and New
Year's Day a begrudging return to school
would soon follow as much as it clearly
brought down his his mood nothing lifted
his spirits like still getting to be out
in the snow and after a long day of
helping his mom take down the tinsel and
pack up the lights while his dad
disposed of the tree Michael was itching
to go outside please Mom he begged as a
box of decorations was placed back in
the attic his hands clasped together in
a pleading gesture please please please
just 5 minutes I I won't go further than
the front yard Michaela sighed partly
from exhaustion but a smile crept on to
her face it was hard not to find her
son's love for the snow endearing all
right but only for 5 minutes she
insisted firmly and I want to see gloves
hat and a scarf not just a coat Mister
with the speed and excitement that she
and her husband had long since lost she
watched Michael race off to gather his
warmest winter coat remember when we
were like that Robert heed a sigh as he
appeared from chopping up that dried out
dehydrated remains of the Christmas tree
no do you Michaela replied with a light
chuckle before long Michael had dawned
his gloves and coat almost a size too
big his scarf was almost wrapping up his
entire head save for the little Bobble
hat that poked out at the top Robert
opened up the front door and his son
stepped out into a world that had been
whitewashed with clear cold snow given
that the Andersons lived on a small
Street in Grain Valley there weren't
many other people around especially not
with another flurry of snowfall moving
closer in the clouds up above but it
wasn't the next snowfall that the
residents of Grain Valley Missouri
should have been worrying about it was
the previous one the one that had
already fallen and what was now hiding
among the snow in the Anderson family's
front yard having few other kids his own
age to play with and not being allowed
to venture too far from the front porch
Michael was content to spend his
precious time Outdoors making snow
angels or practicing throwing snowballs
he had long been trying to get one to
clear the roof of the small house he he
and his parents shared leaving a few
scattered patches of snow embedded on
the roof shingles a few meters from the
front door stood a snowman granted that
was hardly a rare sight at this time of
year especially in the cold weather but
what was so unusual about it was that
Michael hadn't remembered making a
snowman recently his parents hadn't let
him out in the snow on his own since the
start of the New Year given how badly
the downfall and icy winds had been for
the first week of January sure somebody
else could have made it taking a pause
as they passed by the Anderson's front
yard although not Michael Nor either of
his parents had spotted anyone doing
that the Snowman itself was featureless
the white of its ice cold body smeared
with mud and Dead Leaves debris that had
been packed in with the snow used in its
crude construction it was featureless
too whoever had made it hadn't gone to
the effort of giving it a face nor
draped an old scarf over it or given it
a hat it just stood there but not like
any other Snowman there was nothing
welcoming about it in fact it was
fittingly cold given how far away it
stood it was almost as if it was
watching the house curiously Michael
began to approach the Snowman being only
9 years old his imagination was
immediately running with the possibility
that this snow and mulch construct could
be alive much akin to the likes of
Frosty the Snowman little did young
Michael Anderson know that he wasn't far
away from the truth although this
particular snowman wasn't quite the
happy Jolly soul from the much covered
holiday song he hadn't got that much
closer to the Snowman when he heard
something move nearer to where he stood
there was the rustle of leaves and the
Snapping of small Twigs coming up from a
bush next to him Michael couldn't see
what it was but it was far too low to
the ground and too close to the house
for it to be a bird maybe a psum or
raccoon had gotten trapped in the thin
branches and was now scrambling to try
and free itself diverting from
approaching the Snowman he walked closer
to the plant as he did the rustling got
louder more frantic almost hungry there
wasn't just one creature lurking out of
sight beneath the leaves but lots of
something Robert and Michaela had been
sitting indoors watching the TV when
they heard a spine chilling scream
coming from outside instantly they were
both up on their feet racing toward the
front door Robert threw it open and
Michael dashed inside in floods of
fearful tears what happened sweetie
Michaela asked concerned brushing
snowflakes from her son's coat are you
okay did you slip through crying and
sniffling shaking uncontrollably with
how afraid he was Michael couldn't find
the words to answer instead he pointed
through the still open door directly at
the Snowman still standing at the edge
of the front yard how long has that been
there Robert wondered aloud taking a
single step outside don't dad Michael
screamed but it was already too late
something small and Speedy had leaped
out of the snow in the front yard and
latched onto Robert's leg he h as he
felt searing pain bitten by rows of tiny
pointed teeth as sharp as needles and as
bitterly cold as ice stumbling back
Robert Anderson fell over and landed on
the floor in the front hallway
inadvertently carrying whatever had
attacked him into his home both Michela
and Michael screamed in fear as the tiny
creature clawed its way up Robert's leg
while he swatted at it frantically
trying to brush it away before it could
get closer with a blind swipe of his
hand he knocked the creature to the
floor and clambered to his feet arms
outstretched keeping his wife and son
behind him while staring into this
belief at what had bitten him it was
barely more than half a meter tall a
tiny white snowman bulbous bloodied eyes
bulge from its head much like those of
an insect directly between the eyes was
a hole a mouth not unlike a lampri lined
with rows of sharp teeth that all
pointed inwards it reared up and lunged
toward the Anderson family in a display
of aggression that caused all three of
them to jump weily backing away from the
snow creature it was then that Robert
and Michaela noticed what had frightened
their son so much out of the corner
their eye they both simultaneously
caught the sight of the open front door
and the yard Beyond wriggling through
the snow shifting as they moved were
even more of the creatures slithering
towards the house like piranhas catching
the scent of blood in the water and
standing ominously just beyond the
driveway was the Snowman as if it was
the General commanding its troops to
storm the house the Andersons raced
upstairs as a swarm of snow creatures
came spilling into the house crawling
from the yard onto the floor and piling
on top of each other like ants to climb
the stairs naturally Michaela's first
instinct as well as protecting her son
was to call the police while Robert Held
the door to the bedroom shut Michaela
held Michael close and pleaded with the
local grain Valley Police Department to
come and help them although they only
seemed to take the call seriously when
Michael started screaming again one of
the snow creatures had pushed pushed its
way under the door frame and was
sneaking its way towards Robert to
attack him leaving a trail of water
behind it stepping back and Thinking
Fast Robert grabbed a hairdryer and
switched it on full blast the Sudden
Rush of electrically heated air caused
the toothy snow creature to retreat into
a corner refusing to let up Robert got
closer and kept the haird dryer trained
on it eventually causing the creature to
melt until little more was left than a
damp puddle but the victory was
momentary there were still more of them
crawling up the stairs after the
Andersons with their sharp teeth they
were gnawing at the wood of the bedroom
door trying to force their way inside
fortunately for Robert Michaela and
their son Michael they wouldn't be able
to recall the horrific events of January
12th 2019 for much longer by the time
the local police arrived it had become
clear to the officers responding that
they were well out of their depth
especially when one of them was injured
suffering a bite from a snow creature
that was what led the SCP Foundation
being called in and within 15 15 minutes
they had dispatched mobile task force
operatives to secure the anomaly being
some of the foundation's most highly
trained agents it didn't take long for
the MTF to neutralize the carnivorous
snow creatures however they quickly
realized that the mysterious snowmen
that had seemingly spawned the Swarm
could not be melted by any conventional
means nor would it deteriorate naturally
on its own a cover story was issued that
Michael had suffered an accident and
fallen down an open pothole that had
become obscured by heavy snowfall as a
result police officers were dispatched
to help him although the injury
sustained by one officer due to a bite
from a snow creature was never explained
following this the Anderson family was
administered amnestics meaning they
quickly forgot about the whole
terrifying ordeal maybe it was for the
best however young Michael seemed
irreparably changed he never went out to
enjoy the snow again repeatedly
suffering from nightmares about the cold
meanwhile the anomalous snowman was
recovered and thus designated as SCP 4
230 immediately the SCP Foundation did
as their organization does best and
commenced testing with a human subject
no less they quickly discovered that SCP
4230 seemed to generate a sort of field
around itself that could trigger a
distinctive physiological change in any
human being or animal that came within 6
M of the Snowman this process became
known under the designation of SCP
42301 it appeared that Michael Anderson
had managed to unknowingly assist escape
this fate purely by not getting too
close to SCP 4230 staying just far
enough away so as not to trigger SCP
42301 the foundation placed D1
19375 a member of their d-class
personnel within this 6 M radius of the
Snowman and observe the gradual changes
he underwent over the following week for
Simplicity sake we'll refer to D1 19375
as frost a rather fitting moniker and
you'll soon see why within a day of
exposure to the Snowman Frost complained
to a senior researcher that he felt a
lot colder than usual Al though he
exhibited no other observable symptoms
beyond the coughing and sniffling of a
common cold by the following day Frost
was far worse for wear appearing to have
lost significant body mass to the point
where he had appeared to have been
malnourished his cold-like symptoms had
continued accompanied by disorienting
disiness and as if all that wasn't bad
enough his skin tone had seemingly lost
its natural pigment reduced to an
unnaturally pale shade as white as snow
day three saw Frost's body continued to
change rapidly at an alarming rate he
was internally producing an unknown
chemical that looked to be responsible
for enacting certain alterations namely
the dissolving of his femur and fibula
the cold and dizziness were also now
made all the worse by the addition of
pain to the man's lower body Frost even
reported to Foundation researchers
studying him that every movement he was
able to make caused him to suffer
extreme levels of physical pain but yet
rather than attempt to cure its
condition the foundation apathetically
observed noting down the process of SCP
42301 within 5 days of exposure to SCP
4230 naturally occurring substances
within Frost's body had traveled
downwards and solidified this was
followed by the most shocking stage of
the SCP 42301 process so far and one
that made the foundation realize that
these weren't just changes it was a
transformation when day five saw Frost
skeleton physically reshaping itself his
head becoming a sphere and his arms
extending outwards like brittle Twigs it
soon became clear what was happening to
him he was turning into a snowman
rendered immobile and blind a week after
SCP 42301 began to take effect Frost had
started to secrete an unknown substance
this liquid lowered his body temperature
freezing almost instantly and turning
his skin into into an icy white Mass
worryingly similar to snow sure enough
on the Eighth Day the extent of the SCP
42301 process was made evident Frost had
already perished his body now looking
identical to a plain featureless Snowman
no eyes or face just a blank cold slate
but underneath the outer layer of snow
Frost spones and the rest of his organs
were still contained inside from the
outside though he wasn't even human
anymore just an instance of what became
known as SCP
4230 however being turned into another
Snowman by close proximity to SCP 4230
wasn't even the worst part by now you
might be wondering what were those snow
creatures that attack the Andersons
you'd be forgiven for thinking that
perhaps these were rodents or other wild
animals affected by SCP
42301 after all testing has shown that
the process doesn't just alter human
physiology but these carnivorous needle
tooth creatures are known as SCP 4230
DBS and they are nasty little critters
to say the least when a person or animal
is turned into a snowman during SCP
42301 becoming one of these instances is
far from the full extent of the
transformation the test the foundation
conducted on Frost and presumably on
numerous other d-class personnel as well
led to them discovering the further
alterations made when someone becomes an
SCP 4230 a instance their freezing snow
encase bodies become hosts for white
spherical eggs after a subject like
frost becomes an SCP 4230 snowman these
eggs will hatch within 72 hours
producing up to 19 instances of SCP 4230
DB creatures the foundation was quick to
examine these bizarre snow spawn
Gathering up as many as they could for
testing they found that instances of SCP
4230 DB matured to adulthood Hood
remarkably quickly reaching adult hood
in 15 seconds destroying the eggs
containing these creatures seemed to be
an effective way of preventing swarms of
SCP 4230 DBS from getting loose although
the Snowman each egg came from would
also have to be destroyed to achieve
this result also the lifespans of the
smaller snow creatures only lasted for a
total of 24 hours and they would melt
away after a full day of life regardless
of the surrounding temperature SCP 4230
DB seem uninterested in food that was
presented to them specifically one test
involved giving a snow creature a head
of lettuce and a watermelon the creature
regarded the fruit and vegetables with
little interest even refusing to eat
either despite prompts from the
researchers this painted the SCP 4230
dbes as exclusive carnivores which
explained why they attacked the Anderson
family they were trying to eat them
hunting the Andersons as a pack further
testing into SCP 4230 DBS revealed they
had a weak weakness to heat above a
temperature of 40° F during another test
a d-class was sent into a cell with 10
of the carnivorous snow creatures armed
only with a simple lighter an emergency
flare and 1 gallon of gasoline
immediately all 10 of the SCP 4230 DBS
crawled toward the man hungry and
determined him to be a new source of
food that is until they noticed the
lighter he was carrying the d-class
frantically clicked the spark wheel
until the flame danc from the lighter
causing seven of the creatures to back
away from the heat Source cautiously the
d-class was able to kill the remaining
three instances in self-defense causing
them to melt with little effort he was
Far luckier than the subject of the next
test would be another declass was placed
in a holding cell with three of the snow
creatures and much like before they
instantly acknowledged his presence and
began approaching him however the
foundation had sent this member of
d-class in completely unarmed without
even so much as a match to defend
himself the carnivorous Beast made short
work of their helpless victim feeding on
what was left the foundation was able to
dispatch instances of SCP 4230 DB with
relative ease even without waiting for
them to Simply melt after a day the use
of flamethrowers or drawing them into
warmer areas seemed effective enough at
destroying the small snowmen that
hatched out of SCP 4230 daa bodies
however some bright spark at the
foundation decided to test what would
happen if the opposite element was used
against SCP 4230 be creatures were they
vulnerable to the snow despite being
made from a snow likee substance
themselves another test was conducted to
answer this which involved a small
snowball being thrown at one of the SCP
4230 DBS the result of that incident has
been entirely expunge from the
foundation's archives but it's a safe
guess to ask why evidently when attacked
using snow or ice SCP 4230 DBS are
seemingly able to adapt in some way that
is determined to their attacker do they
add snow to their mass or become even
more aggressive it's hard to say given
the redactions but the result of that
final test were deemed so catastrophic
that the foundation banned any further
testing that involved SCP 4230 DBS as
for where SCP 4230 first came from the
foundation is still baffled the first
reported incident involving the Killer
Snowman and the carnivorous creatures It
produced came when the Andersons found
themselves Under Siege by hungry SCP
4230 DBS maybe the Snowman is just a
freak of nature or the result of an
unknown pathogen or microorganism
carried in a snowstorm one fateful night
or perhaps SCP 4230 is something far far
more vicious whatever the case we would
recommend waiting for the sun to come
back out and the snow to melt just to be
safe a streak of warm blood splattered
across the snow steam Rose off it as it
fizzled into the ice crystals below the
the severed leg had just spurted from
lay twitching only a few inches away
torn clean off at the hip like a broken
Barbie doll I think it might have
belonged to Arthur it wasn't the first
time I'd seen limbs cut off hell I've
cut a few off myself in my time yeah
don't worry I'm not a serial killer just
a med student we all were I couldn't say
the same for the nightmare we
encountered up in the mountains that
terrible day the thin cold air was Laden
with screams mine my friends and that
things all that had done to us us all
that it was still doing to us and never
once did it stop shrieking and sobbing
at the top of its lungs like it wasn't
even in control of its actions it didn't
want to do this it just had to the
violence was as inevitable as the sunset
I screamed for Kyle the snow was coming
down thick and fast a curtain of burning
brilliant white I couldn't see anyone
not even that thing that was killing us
the water in my eyes was starting to
freeze up it was cold so damn cold what
the hell was going going on here
suddenly a dark shape was moving towards
me through the wall of falling snow it
was human vaguely moving towards me with
frantic speed I tensed in anticipation
when I then saw Kyle emerging from the
fog he was splattered with blood his
face red from screaming and exertion his
eyes pleaded for help I couldn't give
him the horror caused my body to react
on autopilot with my eyes clamming
closed in Terror all I could do was open
my mouth pointing with a shaking
frostbitten finger and force out a
scream behind you my words were carried
off by the brutal Mountain winds and
with the sounds of Mutilation ahead of
me all I could imagine with eyes clamped
Clos as I hit the frozen ground was a
long gray arm emerging from the flurry
behind Kyle its gnarled clawed fingers
reaching for his head it was meant to be
the vacation of a lifetime the kind of
thing that you could only experience
once but you'd never forget we all
thought in our own ways that we'd look
back on the photos with Misty Eyes when
when we were all old men we didn't know
that within a week of arriving in
Switzerland whether any of us would even
make it to old age would suddenly become
an open question all four of us were
doctors in training even if you don't
know much about the profession it
probably won't surprise you to hear that
there's a lot of practice and education
involved before you can ever really call
yourself a doctor without feeling like a
fraud you need to Ace your SATs then
slog through four years of Premed
another four years of medical school
then the better part of a decade doing
your residency seems a little much I
know but believe me you don't want some
Cowboy sticking his hands in your chest
cavity without all the proper training
but after we finally graduated from
Harvard Med my friends and I decided
that we needed a break before the
profession swallowed us back up again it
was me Brandon Arthur and of course Kyle
a lot of people I attended class with
would probably make a tidy sum over the
course of their Medical Careers many of
them would have made fine doctors but
all of us knew that Kyle Malloy was more
than that he was going to be a truly
great doctor he was smart confident
driven and had the kind of smooth
effortless charm that made you just feel
safe around him where he went we
followed so naturally when he suggested
we take a week-long sojourn in
Switzerland the rest of us were all for
it we expected an easy week of gourmet
cheese fine chocolate and the occasional
Jaun down some old historic districts
the exact kind of relaxing break we
needed after the soul crushing pressure
of 8 years studying the hollowed art of
medicine but of course that wasn't what
Kyle had planned for us it turned out
his tastes were far more extreme than
what the rest of us had in mind his
vision of a Swiss vacation was mostly
Forest hikes Backcountry skiing
snowboarding and a little mountaineering
through the Swiss Alps apparently he'd
spent a good portion of his childhood
taking Swiss vacations and wanted to
give us a little slice of his personal
Paradise as someone who wasn't exactly
crazy about Heights or the cold I can't
pretend I was eager at first but Kyle
always found a way of talking us back
around it wasn't long until we were
booking our tickets then sitting on the
plane watching the mountains get bigger
through the window and our feet were on
Swiss soil it was a beautiful country
never bit as cold as I feared but soon
enough the cold would be the absolute
least of our worries as I glanced over
the breathtaking view of the Alps I had
no idea of the terrible nightmare
lurking out there hidden in the dark
spaces of those great rocks something I
learned in med school is that human
beings are kind of like fleshy time
bombs they're fuse ever burning when you
reach a certain age and believe me that
age is younger than you think the
Assassin that will one day sneak up from
within and take your life is already
waiting inside you the cluster of
malform cells that will one day turn
into an inoperable malignant tumor the
early Whispers of the heart defect that
gives your ticker its planned
obsolescence the microscopic ropes of
defective genes that will one day turn
into Alzheimer's or Parkinson's in some
cases it's just a matter of whether you
can catch it in time but in just as many
cases there really is nothing you can do
you're just waiting for it to get you
after 3 days in Switzerland we were
suiting up in our thick coats and
climbing boots having no idea that the
same principle applied to us except this
wasn't that nasty little assassin within
it was something outside something that
none of our skills or knowledge could
save us from
something very old and very dangerous we
were in Fate's hands now and sometimes
fate can be cruel Kyle was steaming
ahead he didn't just want us to ascend
just any mountain peak he wanted us to
attempt the DOR spites the highest peak
of the Monte Rosa massive and the Alps
as a whole Kyle didn't think anything
less than that would be a challenge
after all this was our once in a
lifetime vacation before we fully
started our residency didn't we want to
make this a truly remarkable experience
and because it was Kyle none of us
disagreed we started at the base of the
monosa and began to rise its lowest
levels barely resembled its Frosty Peak
over 4600 ft above we took pictures of
some of the wildlife the grazing Ibex's
Red Deer and shoa Arthur had brought a
pamphlet on the local Wildlife back at a
tourist friendly Mountain Lodge and took
great joy in pointing out the different
creatures to us as he saw them Brandon
got a good laugh about the fact that
there was a small bird native to the
area known as the that hatch Kyle forged
ahead telling us Tales of his prior
conquests The Climb gradually
transitioned from calm to grueling as we
ascended the mountain I could feel the
blisters forming on my feet as the cold
first made my face Sting and then go
completely numb Arthur still Consulting
his pamphlet expressed excitement to see
a marmot when we finally reached 2,000
ft of elevation Brandon started to
complain vocally pouring himself a cup
of coffee from his thermos Kyle
chastised him for wimping out already
after all he said the hardest parts were
Yet to
Come Oh if only he knew just how right
he was we ascended further feeling the
air thinning and our legs growing
exhausted beneath us I started to resent
Kyle as he forged on despite it all how
could he keep going when the rest of us
were faltering it just wasn't fair when
the rest of us needed to take a breather
we could feel the sting of his silent
judgment he was always so damn perfect
we're almost there he kept saying even
though we all knew it wasn't through
things took a turn during one of our
rest stops we heard this strange noise a
kind of pain wailing or Keening there
was nothing overtly menacing about it
but somehow just hearing that noise
chilled me deeper than any icy gust of
mountain breeze it's difficult to
describe but that terrible sobbing felt
like the purest distillation of true
bottomless despair I've never heard a
more hopeless and mournful noise
referring to his pamphlet again Arthur
speculated that the noise could
potentially be a lynx such creatures
were apparently native to the area and
their calls had a bizarrely human
quality to them but somehow deep down I
knew this thing wasn't human and it
wasn't an animal either whatever was
making those noises defied normal
metrics of categorization to the
surprise of no one me least of all Kyle
decided to lead the way in the direction
of that awful noise Brandon and Arthur
followed him closely over the next
Tundra getting closer and closer to the
sobbing i h back a little further
gripped by the profound sense of dread I
didn't want to find out what was making
this noise I knew deep in my guts that
if ever we found out what was making
that noise something terrible would
happen and then moments later it did I
heard Kyle gasp for the first time ever
the snow was blinding my view and I
couldn't make out what was actually
happening until Arthur ran back toward
my direction and through the blanket of
white snow and with a voice barely
audible through his trembling said that
there was a long Gra great creature he
said it was naked and looked kind of
human but definitely was not I could
barely make out what my buddies were
doing ahead of me but from the looks of
it it seemed like Kyle was walking
closer every cell in my body was
screaming no no no no no no but by that
point it was already far too late for
all of us the creature began to turn
perhaps it was raw animal Instinct that
saved me but I began to turn two almost
in unison to look away from the creature
I just knew that whatever this thing was
I couldn't bear to see it and it was at
that moment as my body hit the snow and
I forced my eyes closed that the
screaming began first I could recognize
the voices of Brandon Arthur and Kyle
screaming and then something worse I can
only assume it was the creature itself
making the most terrible racket
shrieking moaning sobbing and then
ripping and tearing blood spattering
across the snow I just cowered and shook
against the ground as a massacre
unfolded behind me I was listening to my
friends die powerless Kyle all his
strength and direction Stripped Away by
Terror was snatched by the creature as
freezing snowy wind gave it a cloak I
heard Kyle's scream and then never heard
anything from him ever again soon enough
it was quiet once more no noise save for
the howling wind and the quiet sobbing
of the Abomination from the snow I don't
know for sure why the creature spared me
but part of me has always suspected that
it was because I never looked at it I'll
forever be Darkly curious as to what the
Monster truly looked like but my friends
found out and now I'd never see them
again I wandered through the unforgiving
cold for hours fully expecting that my
frozen body would be found in the Alps
hours days or even weeks later I didn't
even care anymore the cold numbed my
skin my limbs and my thoughts at some
point a helicopter descended onto the
mountain side full of men and tactical
gear with insignias I couldn't recognize
they wrapped me in an emergency blanket
and brought me in telling me I required
treatment it all turned a static as we
fluttered away from the mountain side
and all I could think about was the
monster that had taken my friends from
me it was still out there waiting there
is something so captivating about ice it
can be beautiful a shimmering cast of
frost over a meadow or twinkling icicles
on a cottage roof it can also be deadly
a slick of slippery glass on a dark Road
or that same icicle from before knocking
loose and kening towards your head like
a falling dagger it can be a SLE storm
or a mighty Glacier with Secrets buried
beneath its core in a remote part of
Alaska the SCP Foundation discovered a
particularly unusual kind of ice with a
vivid red Hue and some incredibly deadly
potential the foundation investigated
the reports in a remote area on the
Alaskan Coastline after a tribe of Local
Natives came across the mangled bodies
of Shipwrecked hunters in the area in
cased in a block of strange Red Ice
mobile task force beta 7 also known as
the hazmats were sent in to the site to
determine what exactly had occurred and
take samples of any anomalous materials
to be brought back to the nearest
Foundation research site agent Bryce
made the initial visual inspection of
the site and spotted three middle-aged
male bodies further contamination
determined that one of the bodies
referred to as subject zero was the
original point of contamination for
whatever comprised the Red Ice and
caused the men's deaths it has been
posited by the investigation team that
the other men were infected when they
attempted to help subject zero reach
their boat sadly kindness can sometimes
be a killer like that while sweeping the
perimeter agent Hughes spotted human
Footprints leading to the Northeast a
three- men team consisting of agent
Hughes Whitmore and Cassidy was
permitted to follow those tracks and
determine if any survivors or something
worse had escaped the sight exploration
log a009 allows us to determine what
happened next and what the three agents
found Hughes and his team followed the
footprints to the entrance of a cave
with the tracks appearing to lead inside
the entrance of the cave was covered
with an almost solid sheet of ice save
for a crack in the ice about 1 M tall
Beyond this wall agent Whitmore spotted
the body of a young man frozen solid in
the midst of crawling away from
something covered in crystals of Red Ice
with him was a frozen spear gun that
appeared to have been fired just before
the young man's death they could not
touch the body to perform a full
investigation but the way in which he
was gripping his chest indicated that he
might have been fatally stabbed there as
the agents moved further into the cave
they discovered a chamber about 5 or 6 m
in diameter filled filled with red ice
with a pool in the middle the pool was 3
m wide and of an unknown depth as they
pushed further the agents came across a
polar bear startled they fired once at
it before realizing it was already dead
its fur was dotted with crystals of Red
Ice creeping its way across the Bear's
body beyond the polar bear the agent
spotted dozens of bodies all dead
animals there were seals a snow fox and
finally a giant spider with a leg span
of over a meter at first the spider
appeared to be Frozen like the other
creatures but upon further investigation
it appeared to be made of Red Ice agent
Cassidy recognized the spider as SCP
3023 but was told it was impossible when
she pressed for further answers she was
told to ignore it and continue the sweep
agent Whitmore checked the collection of
bodies in the chamber looking for any
humans among them meanwhile Hughes
spotted a spear sticking out of the
enormous a spider indicating a struggle
that took place before it and the young
man at the Cave's entrance froze Hughes
was interrupted in his task as agent
Cassidy called out from deeper in the
cave saying I I think I know where the
spider came from when Hughes followed
the sound of her voice he found
something troubling an aperture about a
meter in diameter absolutely covered in
Red Ice it looked like a tunnel with no
ice at all past its entrance with a dim
light coming from somewhere deep inside
he lost sight of agent Cassidy and
realized she must have gone inside of it
upon further observation Hughes
determined that the walls and the floor
of the tunnel were wet with a red puddle
about a meter in Hughes and Whitmore
called to Cassidy attempting to lead her
back out of the tunnel but received no
response Hughes attempted to go in and
retrieve her but control forbade him
from going any further after a
conversation with control that had been
stricken from the official file Hughes
had relented and agreed to withdraw his
remaining team and exit the site Hughes
and Whitmore left the cave without
further incident and returned to
Foundation headquarters in spite of a
d-class recovery team being sent into
the cave to search for her agent
Cassidy's body was never found the cave
was blocked off from the public in order
to avoid further civilian contact with
the red ice and the red water inside
though the origin of the Red Ice in
Alaska is not known for sure this cave
and the pool deep within it are thought
to be the source of this particular
infestation the official cause of death
listed on record for the bodies found in
Alaska was internal bleeding but what
really happened to them was something
much much worse these men had
transformed and Frozen from the inside
out their blood turning to ice and their
cells going solid one at a time the low
ambient temperature in the area are
thought to have slowed the freezing
process down you heard that right the
cold kept them from freezing faster as
counterintuitive as it sounds this this
prolonged their deaths and kept them
conscious up until the very end even as
their bodies were freezing solid their
very cells turning against them they
were awake and aware of it all these
unfortunate men came into contact with
and lost their lives to a substance
known as SCP
009 SCP 009 in its liquid form
maintained at temperatures between
0° C resembles ordinary distilled water
aside from its bright red color it
behaves opposite of water reaching a
frozen solid state at higher
temperatures and vaporizing into a steam
like gas at temperatures below
-100° an attempt to examine SCP 9's
atomic structure was unable to achieve
conclusive results the substance looks
as if it was made up of normal water
molecules though obviously it is much
more than simple water SCP 009 appears
relatively harmless at first glance but
its real dangerous potential lies in its
ability to contaminate water-based
Solutions transferring its properties to
them a contaminated liquid begins to
exhibit the same unusual behavior as SCP
009 freezing at temperatures above 0°
and vaporizing at temperatures below
-100 it has been shown to effectively
contaminate ice steam tea fruit juice
seawater and blood in a process taking
between 3 minutes and several hours
these concerning properties raised
questions about what SCP 009 and liquids
contaminated by it might do if they made
contact with a human body several
d-class Personnel were used as test
subjects exposed to SCP 009 in a
controlled environment and observed from
a safe distance when first exposed to
SCP 009 the test subjects reported
nothing unusual except a slight
sensation of warming on the surface of
their skin then Frost began to form
across the surface of the exposed area
as the subject's body heat raised the
substance's temperature this process
took between a minute and a few hours
during which ice crystals began to form
along the top layer of the skin this
stage is known as surface conversion in
the next stage deep tissue conversion
the continued increase in SCP 9's
temperature causes a ripple effect of
reactions through the subject's body ice
crystals forming in the cells and
throughout the blood the subject
remained alive and conscious during the
stage details about the fourth stage of
the process have been expunged from the
official record but it is safe to say
that something horrible happened after
several of these experiments were
conducted testing on live d-class
subjects was officially discontinued
there was a possibility of
experimentation on SCP 009 regarding its
potential application to Cold Fusion but
this was also eventually discontinued
following a disastrous accident at an
unnamed Foundation test site the site
was completely destroyed and pieces of
the lead agent conducting the cold
fusion research have still not been
recovered for now SCP 009 is kept under
strict containment and only tested under
particular highly regulated
circumstances SCP 009 is kept in a
sealed storage tank of heat resistant
alloy it is not to be exposed to any
temperatures higher than 0° C unless
there is official Foundation sanction
testing being done no water-based
liquids are allowed within 30 m of the
containment area the storage tank is
outfitted with temperature sensors that
are to be monitored at all times in
order to prevent the temperature within
from rising and is kept cold by three
different cooling units if the sensors
or cooling units malfunction for any
reason they must be fixed immediately to
prevent disaster when testing is done on
SCP 009 the containment area is kept in
a vacuum and the Personnel working with
it must wear protective gear after
testing all involved personnel must
quarantine for at least 12 hours any
living organisms contaminated by SCP 009
must be terminated promptly while the
exact origins of SCP 009 are unclear it
clearly does not follow the laws of
nature as we understand them a
foundation expert in xenos spatial
physics suggested that SCP 009 may have
come from a universe with alternate laws
of physics explaining its reversal of
the ordinary conditions for states of
matter during an instance of SCP 5 07
The Reluctant Dimension Hopper shifting
into an alternate universe an instance
of SCP 009 was unexpectedly observed
that may help confirm this theory in the
test area where SCP 507 appeared red
snow fell for about 27 minutes grass
touched by this red snow began to react
and freeze over within a few minutes the
other plant life touched by the snow
turned bright red and expanded to a
larger size it also began to sprout
bright blue tentacles covered with red
mucilage upon closer examination the
mucilage turned out to be comprised of
small amounts of SCP
009 this raised additional questions for
instance how are these plants able to
survive constant exposure to SCP 009
this matter is currently under
investigation but the prevailing theory
is that this plant is an example of
plant life from SCP 9's native Universe
whatever it is and wherever it comes
from it should not be allowed to come
into contact with earth-based Organic
life forms well not unless being
horrifically frozen to death by your own
body feels like an appealing experience
to you the coastline where SCP 009 was
initially discovered and its first
victims on record were found was located
very close to the ocean thankfully the
exact area of contamination was dry and
cold enough to keep the Red Ice from
spreading but if it had been even a few
meters closer to the water it could have
spread into the North Pacific ocean with
contamination of that scale it could
have very easily infected thousands of
people perhaps spreading into other
bodies of water and triggering a global
Extinction event because of this threat
several members of the SCP Foundation
proposed that SCP 009 be upgraded to ker
class in order to reflect its danger to
humanity however this request was denied
due to the currently effective
containment measures in place the Red
Ice is unable to spread to new hosts
infecting the water supply and turning
all living things into frozen husks for
now let's just hope we don't see any red
snow storms anytime soon climbers
attempting to summon Mount Everest and
stand on the top of the world have their
work cut out for them dangers are
everywhere on the long climb there's a
risk of extreme altitude sickness
unpredictable winds and freezing weather
there's also the threat of avalanches
great Unstoppable tidal waves of snow
that can bury a person alive in seconds
or or strand them leaving them to freeze
to death cold and alone it's a sad
reality that not everyone that visits
Everest comes back down again and rarely
does a climbing season go by that the
mountain doesn't claim yet another
victim situated on the border between
China and Nepal in a subrange of the
Himalayas of Tibet Everest is one of the
seven wonders of the natural world with
an elevation of
29,31 Ft or
8,848 M Mount Everest has attracted many
experienced mountain climbers over the
decades but even for the most
experienced Mountaineers the Ascension
up its snowy slopes is far from Easy
deaths occurring on Mount Everest are
nothing new and hundreds of people are
believed to have died attempting to
ascend the treacherous Peak sadly due to
the risks involved with carrying heavy
loads down off the mountain many of
those who die on
everestsolar your own body up and down
Everest and in many situations bringing
a body back down is simply impossible
the bodies of these lost souls are
scattered all across and sometimes
underneath the surface of Mount Everest
but some of those bodies are different
from the others and have a special name
within the files of the SCP Foundation
they call them SCP
5140 SCP 5140 is the designation given
to a number of frozen bodies which are
found all across Everest it is unclear
exactly how many instances of SCP 5140
there are though some estimates have
placed the number at somewhere between 1
and 200 at present it is unknown if all
the instances of SCP 5140 are dead
bodies belonging to climbers who met
tragedy on the tallest mountain in the
world or if some of them are something
else entirely but while their origin is
unclear if you come into contact with a
5140 instance there won't be any down
that it's different from the normal body
of a dead climber that's because SCP
5140 corpses are a lot like vampires in
some ways that isn't to say that they
actually are vampires they certainly are
not Undead and cannot function after
death but much like a vampire
traditionally drains blood to survive
these bodies drain heat SCP 5140 corpses
are ectoentropic meaning they do not
adhere to the normal laws of
thermodynamics whenever these cavers are
exposed to sources of heat including
human body heat the corpse will
instantly drain the source of any and
all thermal energy however the
temperature of these SCP 5140 bodies
remains the same regardless of how much
heat they are able to drain staying at a
constant 50° F or 10° C should any
living person come into direct contact
with one of the SCP 5140 corpses the
body will absorb their natural body heat
bringing their victim's own temperature
down to 10° C and causing them to die
and once they have died their body then
becomes a new instance of SCP 5140 as a
quick side note this might feel vaguely
reminiscent of another anomaly which
features seemingly inert dead bodies
that are hazardous to anyone around them
SCP
2316 this anomaly is a powerful mimetic
Hazard consisting of a large number of
drowned human corpses these corpses are
extremely hazardous to approach at even
a considerable distance as the mimetic
hazard inherent to the anomaly causes
those affected to recognize the bodies
in the water as people they know
particularly from their childhood like a
Sirens call the victims are lured into
the water believing that the familiar
bodies are calling to them if the
victims aren't stopped quarantined and
given amnestic treatment they are
essentially considered lost they will
walk into the water and be absorbed into
the collective becoming just another
body floating in the water while the
foundation doesn't currently believe
that there is any official connection
between the two anomalies the
similarities are undeniable and worth
taking into consideration moving on at
present it is unclear whether SCP 5140
corpses are caused by some sort of
infection or parasite that spreads among
the bodies uncovered at Mount Everest if
this is the case the foundation has yet
to uncover the patient zero the root
cause of these infected bodies there is
also little to determine why a deceased
body requires the absorption of heat as
well as how it achieves this and also
keeps its own temperature low but not
frozen given that interacting with an
instance of SCP 5140 can be fatal it
does seem that these anomalous
properties can be passed through contact
and exposure like a disease or a
parasite but there have been no observed
anomalous effects among any living
person visiting Mount Everest there is a
possibility that that the SCP 5140
corpses have developed some form of
postumus mutation that has come as a
result of being killed during an Everest
avalanche and buried in the snow their
bodies starved of heat after death after
all Everest is known for its cold
temperatures occasionally reaching as
low as 1° F or
-7° C not to mention the difference in
air pressure at such high altitudes as
well as frequent high-speed freezing
cold winds at the summit of Mount
Everest with wind speeds can reach up to
280 kmph that is equivalent to 175 mph
and high-speed winds have even been
known to catch mountain climbers off
guard and send them plummeting to their
deaths perhaps the combination of these
conditions the freezing temperature the
air pressure and the winds have
triggered some sort of change in a
number of the bodies unfortunate enough
to never leave the snow covered slopes
of Mount Everest either that or these
abandoned corpses left in such EXT
extreme cold could be the perfect home
maybe some form of unknown and so far
undetected parasite is capable of
inhabiting these frozen bodies and can
spread to other living hosts by draining
them of their body heat stranger things
have certainly happened at the SCP
Foundation and that could possibly
explain why anyone interacting with an
SCP 5140 corpse meets the same Grizzly
fate regardless of what causes these
abnormalities or why the SCP 5140 bodies
have only been covered at Mount Everest
close contact with the corpses often
result in casualties and fatalities
naturally this is a cost the SCP
Foundation likes to avoid as often as it
can the nasty habit SCP 5140 corpses
have of draining a person's body heat
makes it impractical to bring them back
to a foundation research facility for
testing as does the fact that they're on
the tallest mountain in the world
instead MTF Delta 14 have been tasked
with keeping these heat thirsty cavers
contained to mount ever
mobile task force Delta 14 also known
under the code name Winter Wonderland is
formed of a group of particularly Adept
Mountaineers and experts in
understanding and adapting to
particularly brutal terrain without
drawing attention to themselves these
covert operatives are task with
periodically climbing Mount Everest and
keeping SCP 5140 contained it is this
team's job to locate any new instance of
SCP 5140 bodies and bury them in the
snow in doing so the goal is to prevent
any unwitting mountain climbers from
stumbling upon one of these bodies and
potentially becoming a new instance
themselves meanwhile the foundation is
pushing for both Nepal and Tibet to
tighten restrictions on climbing permits
but of course the money that Mount
Everest tourism brings to these two
countries has likely impeded this
according to the foundation's file on
SCP 5140 an incident occurred during one
of mobile task force Delta 14's annual
Everest Expeditions members of MTF Delta
14 had been Tri traversing towards the
Everest summit encountering more and
more of the SCP 5140 bodies as they made
their way up the mountain just as they
were instructed to do so the team buried
each of the Frozen corpses they came
across under a blanket of snow the Delta
14s noticed though that there had been a
much higher number of the frosty cavers
on this Mission speculating that perhaps
Mount Everest's high winds had blown the
snow off of ones they had already buried
on previous missions one of the Delta
14s a man named Charlie Smith was in
correspondents with his colleagues at
their base camp Charlie reported that
one of his fellow winter wonderlands
Patrick had touched one of the SCP 5140
corpses when the team reached the summit
and that he was now buried according to
protocols after becoming an SCP 5140
instance himself as they began their
descent from a top Everest Charlie sent
an urgent communication to base camp
reporting that he'd uncovered three more
SCP 5140 bodies at an abandoned campsite
except these three instances were
different from any he had encountered
before these corpses Were Somehow still
moving attempting to hurry down the
mountain Charlie reported that a mass of
SCP 5140 corpses were blocking his path
and draining another one of his
squadmates Arnold of his body heat to
make him one of them Arnold had been
carrying the team's Provisions including
their oxygen reserves to combat the lack
of breathable Air at Mount Everest's
high altitude Charlie tried in vain to
use his flare gun to clear the path
hoping to distract the now walking
cavers with a heat Source but it had no
effect his final message to base camp
warned the rest of Delta 14 to not come
to the summit of Everest with Charlie
frantically urging them to not let
climbers anywhere near it his final
message simply stated that the mountain
is danger a rescue division of mobile
task force Delta 14 arrived just under 2
hours later tracking Charlie's last
known location via a GPS Beacon
strangely despite the Frantic messages
from Charlie there were no signs of any
SCP 5140 instances none of the piles of
corpses he had warned them about could
be seen above the snow and certainly
none of them were moving it wasn't long
before the rescue team found Charlie
though he was dead but not drained of
heat or turned into another instance of
SCP 5140 no sadly after bringing their
fallen comrade back to base an autopsy
revealed that Charlie had died likely
the same way so many other Climbers on
Everest had he had suffered from a lack
of oxygen further examp examination of
his gear revealed that Charlie's oxygen
intake valve had been damaged earlier
while the squad had been climbing to the
summit of Mount Everest his teammates
Arnold Hillary and Patrick Edmund were
also discovered on the mountain but only
Patrick had been turned into an SCP 5140
instance Arnold had simply died from
exposure just like Charlie the rescue
team concluded that due to lack of
adequate oxygen Charlie Smith had
hallucinated the sight of SCP 5140
corpses moving and blocking his path
spending his final moments in Terror as
the Mountain's conditions slowly killed
him the foundation is still unsure
exactly what caused his bodies to become
instances of SCP 5140 or even how many
of them are on Everest but a major and
troubling development has recently been
made after an increase in global
temperature led to a large Avalanche
that resulted in a large portion of the
mountain that had previously been
covered in thick snow being exposed the
foundation sent planes that were
equipped with thermal imaging equipment
to scan the mountain what they found was
as confusing as it was terrifying the
SCP 5140 corpses aren't just spread
across the surface of Mount Everest they
are much of Everest the mountain itself
is just a huge pile of corpses just
waiting to drain the life from anyone
who attempts to scale it and turn them
into a permanent part of the peak so if
you were planning a trip to the
Himalayas hoping to scratch climb Mount
Everest off your bucket list maybe give
it a pass otherwise you might find that
the climb is even colder than you were
expecting expecting even as a small kid
all you ever wanted was to climb your
little toes dangle off the edge of the
wooden frame of your bunk bed your
action figures are down below on the
carpet looking as small as ants seeing
the world from this height is an
adrenaline rush like no other but soon
you outgrow your bunk bed and you return
to the level the rest of the world is
living on to recapture the feeling you
ride your bike to the park where you
climb the tallest slide and sit perched
at its peak the feeling of the bunk bed
comes back to you up here you're closer
to the stars and further from your
homework you think I'm never going back
down but soon there is a line of
children on the slide's ladder barking
at you calling you a scaredy-cat telling
you to hurry up already a hand presses
into your back and pushes you forward
your small body tumbles down the slide
just like that your feet are in the sand
you're at the same altitude as everyone
else no longer special in your elevation
but you're not done you're determined to
go elsewhere and upward you start
climbing trees first just small ones
with bumpy bark for your feet to use
like rungs on a ladder it feels good up
there but soon you notice you're not
alone you're sharing the space with
squirrels and caterpillars it's not that
you're afraid of these little creatures
but you want to go to a height few else
ever had you move on to a larger tree
this one you even even need tools to
climb you lasso a rope around a branch
and pull yourself up to get even higher
you wear wide receiver gloves Band by
the NFL so that your hands are sticky
enough to grip even the smallest
protrusions of bar soon you reach the
top now at the highest sturdy branch of
the largest tree you look down at the
world and see it in perfect order you
appear them down there it is beautiful
but then a noise a no noise too loud to
have come from below next to you you see
a bird it smugly smirks at you and flaps
its wings and flies higher one-upping
your accomplishment it lands on a Tiny
Branch above you reaching the actual
tippy top that you couldn't reach and
it's then you realize that the feeling
you're chasing isn't just so that you
can look down on the earth and scoff but
so you can look up at the world and
wonder so you spend your life with your
chin to the sky feet following your game
everything you do every action you take
is in the name of elevation you chose a
career in being a union lineman you work
the night shifts climbing up telephone
poles your happiest farthest from the
ground every November you vacation to
New York where you run up the Empire
State Building just to Taste New Heights
you Summit 86 flights
1,576 stairs but no matter what extremes
you go to you feel like there is
something up there still still Out Of
Reach waiting for you there is only one
thing that will satisfy you Mount
Everest if you can just reach the summit
you promise yourself your wife your God
and your family that you'll stop
straining your neck upward that you'll
enjoy what is in plain sight that you'll
settle down and live the life that's
right there in front of you you begin to
study for your two-month climb you learn
about the Sub-Zero temperatures you
learn about the Journey's physical
demands on your body you learn about
navigation communication and preparation
but what you don't learn about or rather
can't learn about is the anomaly that
awaits you unfortunately some lessons
are omitted from books left to be
learned only by experience and by that
time I'm afraid it'll be much too late
in the lecture to get a passing grade
the day comes and You Begin your mission
to the Mountain's Peak there's something
otherworldly about it the way you move
up this mountain it isn't just a matter
of Labor there's a spirituality within
the journey you feel as if you're
floating being pushed toward the heavens
by some generous being behind you but
what is it that actually pushes you
upward could it be as simple an answer
as willpower determination skill no you
felt those before and while they have
surely powered many men to do great
things this force is different it is not
so much that it is pushing you forward
it is more like it is pulling you up or
rather lurring you in you're amazed at
how effortless the journey is at least
it is up until now upon reaching the
8,000 M Mark also known as the death
zone you begin to feel uneasy no longer
is each step light and graceful now it
feels like your boots are filled with
cement you could swear your backpack is
full of bricks for a moment you think
you have lost your beanie and gloves
because your ears and fingers are ice
cold the journey suddenly becomes long
and grueling dangerous and difficult you
use every muscle in your body to climb
this thing you have to you use every bit
of mental concentration just to keep
moving you have to but why why now could
it be as simple an answer as exhaustion
accumulated fatigue how could it be
you've prepared as much as humanly
possible not just in your training but
in your life you were meant for this
moment but now now the moment is
refusing your Embrace nothing you could
have done could have prepared you for
this an amorphous feeling settles into
your gut you don't understand it
entirely but you anticipate something
bad is about to happen and it is at this
moment that you wish you wouldn't have
traveled alone you wish you had a
partner to reassure you that everything
would be okay you wish you had someone a
few steps in front encouraging you
forward you stop and stare ahead and
imagine it you imagine a friend to
struggle with to laugh with to succeed
with and then suddenly you don't have to
imagine any longer you see someone but
how last you heard you were the only one
to be traveling this way could it be an
illusion you squint harder and harder
trying to make sense of what you're
actually seeing a human or at least a
humanlike thing it is wearing all white
mountaineering clothes and Boots there
is something about the clothes and boots
that makes you think they might not even
be clothes or boots at all but more like
an extension of Flesh although they
appear to be made of traditional
clothing materials they seem to be one
with the figure's body and the figure's
body seems to be one with the mountain
while you are on a mountain thousands of
miles away from your family this thing
is at home but what is it you squint
through specks of snow splashing across
your vision it seems about average human
height and average human and wait could
it be simply an average sized human you
want to make this conclusion with your
mind but your eyes won't let you at this
distance it is still just a figure but
as he approaches you and the possibility
of a companion sinks in you become more
optimistic and you think maybe this
figure can be a friend little do you
know you have just met a mountain
climber's biggest foe meet SCP
1529 you notice its black goggles and
then strange enough you can't stop
noticing them you find it impossible to
break eye contact with you are
physically unable to turn away not only
that but you do not have any desire to
turn away either you are drawn into its
gaze and you are happy to be there for
the first time in your entire life you
are content with where you are at you no
longer care about climbing Mount Everest
you strive no longer for great physical
or metaphorical Heights you are more
than okay with where where you are at
right here right now and now you begin
to feel very warm and comfortable and
you have a sudden urge to sit down and
relax for a while the unhurried pace of
your movements matches the stone swaying
scene at a reggae concert you sit down
and rock back and forth you are at peace
in this idleness almost in a sedated
State of Consciousness you misinterpret
the signs of this dangerous anomaly as a
sign of personal growth you believe
wholeheartedly that this is who you are
now and that this is who you are always
meant to be with new found peace you
settle into the snow you embrace the
moment and that's when it gets even
worse as CP 1529 moves towards you
navigating the mountain with ease using
just his hands and feet no gear needed
as its arrival looms there is nothing
you can do but wait but what exactly are
you waiting for what's going on where
did this thing come from well you
wouldn't be the first to ask L the
subject of incident
15291 questioned this himself L was
reportedly killed during an encounter
with SCP 1529 when it abruptly became
active shortly after he had reached the
Mountain's Summit however L was
eventually found alive when another team
reached his position nearly 2 days later
and removed him safely from the mountain
he required fingertip and Tow
amputations due to frostbite but
otherwise made a full recovery while
still in the hospital an agent of the
foundation was able to ask him questions
and figure out what he had experienced
it was a difficult time for Al but it
was an exciting time for the foundation
from what they previously understood of
SCP 1529 they never thought they would
hear the truth straight from the
victim's mouth until then it was only
ever told through their autopsy L was on
his way down the mountain he was proud
and excited having reached the top and
accomplished his life's goal but he
understood the Trek Back was no easy I
that if he didn't stay focused he would
end up dead like so many others he
noticed his hood was off and he stopped
to adjust it no big deal just a quick
fix little did El know it would lead to
such hardships during his wardrobe
malfunction his group made their way
about 6 M ahead of him and it was then
standing in his new found loneliness
that he saw SCP 1529 coming over the
ridge L was a jovial fellow his impulse
wasn't to fear the figure instead he
shouted and waved assuming the figure to
be another climber left behind by his
mates suddenly it looked right at him
and that's when it started to happen El
felt happy and relieved it was like all
the pain and the soreness and the chill
were gone no longer did he have blisters
on his feet he could feel his toes again
it was like he was back home in front of
the fireplace it was as if the journey
was complete and his efforts had been
rewarded l no longer minded the mission
back down he felt perfectly fine where
he was but even still while his body was
content his gut didn't trust the feeling
something was off why would L go all
this way only to become complacent he
kept thinking he kept fighting the urges
to relax to succumb to supposed feelings
of warmth he knew the stories of men who
felt similar misleading Sensations when
your body starts to cool down to an
extreme degree your blood vessels dilate
and you start to feel like you're
actually warming up in these instants is
people often tear off their clothes
because they feel like they are burning
up and need to cool down next thing they
know they're naked and frozen to death
El would not go like that he had too
much pride he tried to shrug off the
feelings of warmth but before he even
could it was stripped from him as SCP
1529 got closer suddenly all of the Heat
and comfort El had experienced was gone
he was cold colder than he had ever been
before his fingers and face no longer
had feeling his lips peeled snapped and
cracked they were frozen his legs
cramped up he buckled at the knees and
dropped into the snow he tried to yell
for help but all that came out was a
soft and pathetic whimper SCP 1529
grabbed 's shoulders and pulled him
towards his face L looked into his
goggles having no other choice he saw
images in the lenses and suddenly it was
as if El was watching a film or rather
brief vignettes he saw people hot tubs
relaxing a woman curled up by an open
fire a couple sunbathing on the beach El
recognized all these warm and happy
people they were people he had seen on
the way up the mountain but not the way
down it only took a moment for El to
realized they were people who had fallen
to SCP 1529 it was then L knew he had to
resist but SCP 1529 doesn't take well to
Defiance the images and the goggles
changed from happy to horror the same
people were now laying in the snow half
dead El couldn't manage to look at it
for another second he balled his fist
with whatever strength God was willing
to lend him he tried to strike SCP 1529
in the goggles his arms moved slowly at
first like punching in a dream it was
moving as if the air it traveled through
was thick Jell-O suddenly it snapped
into full speed and drilled as SCP 1529
Square in the center of his goggles
ultimately leading to El's rescue but
this is no princess movie not everyone
is so lucky to be rescued this brings us
back to you yes you wait you didn't
think that brief deviation from second
person would last forever did you so
where were we or should I say where were
you oh yes you're sitting in the snow
patiently waiting for SCP 1529 to kill
you and as you wait for its arrival you
think back to the survival lessons that
L taught you now you can see why I
suddenly changed to third person earlier
so you're thinking of L and how he
punched SCP 1529 and you're thinking
you'll do the same but what you can
learn from l so SCP 1529 may have
learned as well would such a threatening
creature ever be defeated in the same
way twice you notice that its goggles
have been repaired and you intend on
cracking them open like an egg but your
fist won't close your arm won't raise
you keep trying to start up your
strength like an old pickup truck
nothing your luck eludes you you feel
helpless and so you sit in the snow and
wait you can't ball up your fingers into
two fists but you can bring one Palm to
the other and pray you pray for help
from your God above your prayers however
are misguided yes there is help above
but it's not a God that's watching over
you but rather the foundation's aerial
surveillance a well-oiled system of
spyware born out of necessity designed
after the incident known as SCP
15292 SCP 15292 occurred when an agent
located in a permanent facility in China
observed as CP 1529 through a telescope
while it was active near the summit of
the mountain that day SCP 1529 looked
directly into the telescope the agent
immediately reported symptoms consistent
with an SCP 1529 encounter and reported
that SCP 1529 had begun descending the
mountain in the direction of the
permanent facility similar to the
stories on the mountain the agent 2 was
unable to pull himself away from the
telescope after 17 minutes under the
spell of SCP 1529 he was rushed to the
facility s Bay and found to have signs
of frostbite in the fingers and toes
despite having remained indoors for the
duration of the encounter the foundation
then had to rethink its approach to
surveilling SCP
1529 when SCP 15 29 is active
surveillance is now conducted by means
of an automated telescope with a video
feed playing at 7 Seconds delay to avoid
a repeat incident of incident
15292 when necessary and safe additional
observation is done by way of helicopter
and airplane furthermore the bodies of
any hikers who encounter SCP 1529 are
removed from the mountain as soon as
possible for autopsy and Disposal the
foundation attributes all SCP 1529
related casual to natural causes
relating to altitude sickness and
hypothermia any survivors or Witnesses
are debriefed and administered a Class B
amnestic and for even further safety
measures mobile task force s
29029 also known as Alpine Echo remains
on standby at all times at the
foundation monitoring station in a
pressurized environment a climatized to
7,900 m above sea level in the event
that a recurrence of incident 15291
occurs Alpine echko deploys to the
mountain by helicopter and so by the
grace of the foundation you will be
saved although sitting helplessly in the
snow you may feel your current state of
existence can be best described by the
phrase dead meat you are more than
likely to be saved than slaughtered even
still there is no comfort in the future
on the mountain right here right now you
are looking up and locking eyes with SCP
1529 your whole life has come to this
moment all you ever wanted as a child
was to climb the highest Heights
aspiring upward has brought you so many
good things Adventures Financial
stability respect everything you have in
your life is from the simple fact that
you did not settle for what you had but
strived for what was above you but now
this same impulse has gotten you in a
world of trouble had you just looked at
where you were instead of where you
wanted to be you would have been okay if
you had just felt the snow Beneath Your
Feet you would have been okay but
instead you looked up how you always did
you looked up toward the goal and away
from the present and look where it has
led you the message of this story is
clear but if for some reason we resist
the lesson passed down from one
generation of thinkers to the next SCP
1529 is out there waiting for us to turn
over our shoulder and look back or tilt
our chin and look up and at that point
it will Force the moral on you again
giving you no other option but to
experience its wrath right here right
now I was chasing him the poor soul who
saw me he was wearing a thick red winter
coat and glasses climbing up the side of
the mountain with a sharp little tool if
I had known he was coming I I would have
run of course I would have run but it
was already too late the second he saw
me saw my horrible ug ugly face it was
already over I felt all those familiar
feelings Bubble Up I knew as well as I
knew anything in my life that I would
need to kill him my name well I I don't
know my name not really I think I had
one once a long long time ago I don't
think I always look like this like this
big ugly monster but who can say those
memories were blown away like a snow
drift life this life at least least has
never been easy for me I don't like
hurting people but at least up there in
the mountains people didn't see me that
often how could I know about the strange
men who would come for me how could I
possibly know that it was all going to
get so much worse the poor man in the
red coat who saw me tried his best to
run I think my crying frightened him I I
wish my mouth could make words if I
could I would have told him how sorry I
was but it didn't matter anymore I kept
kept moving towards him like I was being
pulled Along by some invisible leash in
his Direction I tried to stop I tried to
think really hard and to focus I kept
telling myself no not this time you're
better than this you can let this one go
before the sentence is even fully formed
in my mind I'm already there I'm already
on top of him I look down and see his
terrified face tears Frozen on his
cheeks eyes wide with horror you can't
even begin to describe if you have seen
my face he was still looking at me it
hurt that he was still looking at me I
leaned in and opened my mouth wide
enough to swallow him whole soon enough
there was nothing left of the man in the
red coat and I was alone again all I
could think to do was sit there on the
freezing mountain side and weep why did
I keep doing this why couldn't I stop
myself I asked myself these questions
again and again but I never got an
answer it felt like I knew myself a
little less every single day sometime
later I don't know how many days weeks
or months two huge black noisy creatures
came towards me out of the sky the
second I saw them I turned and started
moving away I couldn't let those
creatures see me I knew something
terrible would happen if they did it was
best to just move away let them leave me
alone nobody had to die what I didn't
know was that I was the reason they were
there the two flying black creatures
landed on on the mountain behind me and
groups of people climbed out carrying
strange objects I didn't recognize I
huddled myself away and a corner as one
of the men came towards me I was so
afraid I couldn't stop myself from
crying I didn't have the words I
couldn't tell them how much danger they
were in couldn't tell them that I didn't
want to hurt them that they should just
leave me here but it was already too
late one of the strange men walked right
in front of me and saw my face he said
Jesus this thing is one ugly I started
screaming I I couldn't help myself my
head started going fuzzy and my heart
hurt the man who'd seen my face was
already backing away knowing that just a
few seconds too late that he'd made an
awful mistake it wouldn't save him now
nothing could save him I tried to stop
myself but trying hurt it just made me
scream louder I turned and lunged at him
but that made things worse now so many
of the others had seen my face too with
fat wet tears rolling down my cheeks I
knew that I would have to destroy them
all even though I didn't want to but
this time they fought back I suddenly
heard all these horrible loud noises all
around me and felt white hot pain all
over my body they were shooting at me
both with the objects they held and
other even larger weapons attached to
their strange flying vehicles this made
my confusion and anger even worse I went
berserk jumping at them and attacking
them with my claws and teeth they may
have been able to hurt me more than
ordinary people they were just as easy
to destroy as anyone not that it made me
feel any less terrible for doing it even
though they did attack me first who were
these strange aggressive people and why
had they come here to attack me soon
enough I destroyed all the ones who had
seen my face there was nothing left to
do but just sit there and weep again I
felt so terrible about everything I'd
done to them it was a pain deep deep in
my chest but then suddenly everything
went black and a sack was pulled over my
head I couldn't see who did it and I'm
glad I didn't more importantly they
didn't see me I think after that they
bundled me onto one of their flying
vehicles and took me away I had no idea
where I'd end up next all I could do was
stand there with a bag over my head and
cry still blinded and after a long
period of flying through the air I was
pulled out of the vehicle and dragged
away somewhere I feel grateful that I
didn't know if I was here to be punished
it was probably what I deserved soon
enough I was brought into a room where a
bunch of strangers were looking at me I
later learned that one of these
strangers was called Dr Dan and Dr Dan
seemed very interested in what had
happened back on the mountain the one
who put the bag over my head was talking
to Dr Dan he said that thing killed all
my men tore through them like tissue
paper our Heavy Artillery barely slowed
it down and it reached generated any
damage it sustained almost immediately
fascinating Dr Dan said and yet it seems
so docile now why what activated its
rage State during the confrontation
Connor looked at its face that's when it
went ballistic hearing the story told
again I started to weep it was true
everything they were saying was true I
killed all those poor people even though
I I couldn't help it there was no place
for me in this world if all I could do
was was hurt people I'd be better off
not existing at all everything was a bit
of a blur after that the next time the
bag was removed I was in some kind of
room a perfect Cube that clanked and
clunked every time I moved around in it
no windows no doors probably for the
best all I could do was pace around this
little Cube and wait wait until Dr Dan
was ready to conduct more of his tests I
never felt more empty and alone but at
least I couldn't hurt anyone here thank
heavens for small mercies sometime later
I was pged again and taken out of the
cube I don't know where they took me but
suddenly I felt that terrible Feeling
Again knowing that someone out there had
seen my awful ugly face knowing that no
matter what I really wanted to do I had
to destroy them it was the only way but
how they seen my face while I was
wearing the bag it didn't make sense
none of it made any sense I felt the
strong tug of the invisible leash again
pulling me towards the one who'd seen me
I screamed and roared and wailed and
tore off the bag I started Galloping
across the land in front of me all
Barren and empty until I reached the
water I was right next to the ocean I
leaped in and started diving getting
deeper deeper deeper eventually I found
a strange metal sphere somehow I knew
just the one who had seen my face was
somewhere in there I tore it open and
found him a man in an orange jumpsuit he
screamed as water filled his lungs
moments later he was gone I swam back to
shore tears dissolving in the ocean
where the strange man bagged me again
and I was back in the cube it was a
moment of calm soon things were going to
get so much worse that terrible day it
happened a lot like last time the time
next to the ocean I was inside my cube
when I felt that terrible feeling the
sensation of being looked at this time I
I somehow sensed that the one who saw me
was even further away I said to myself
this time I'd resist I'd stop myself
nobody would be hurt but resisting the
pole hurt me even more all I could do
was wait and Howl in terrible pain as I
heard people panicking and scrambling
outside the walls of my room soon enough
it was too late I couldn't stop myself I
needed to find the one who saw me and
Destroy them the walls gave way like wet
sand as I tore through them there were
so many people in white coats standing
around the room a terrible smelling gas
that burned my throat flooded the room
killing most of the people around me but
as always I survived and I started
running feeling the pull towards the
person who saw my face I busted through
walls and galloped across the ground
feeling the miles tick by each second I
could hear the distant hum of more of
those flying vehicles in the air behind
me but it didn't matter none of him
mattered all that mattered was finding
the one who saw me and wiping them off
the face of the Earth no matter how
awful it made me feel inside soon I
arrived at a town where everyone was
gathered in the center they all turned
and looked at me and I could feel the
rage rising to a fever pitch there were
so many of them all those poor people
and not long after more people with guns
arrived wearing strange goggles they all
looked at my face too I I couldn't help
it I'm so sorry sorry I just couldn't
help it I try not to think about how
many people I killed that day but soon
enough a bag was placed back over my
head and I was dragged back to my room
which they'd rebuil while I was gone I
remained in there for a long time just
weeping consumed by my own seemingly
endless sadness until one day some time
later I was dragged out of my room and
taken to another chamber I could hear
something that wasn't human breathing
when they pulled the bag off my head I
was standing across from a monster
staring right at my face a huge terrible
reptile with a thick hide and giant
Claws and teeth it hissed when it saw me
it was happening again the pain started
I was weeping and wailing was this all
my life would ever be a mix of silence
and violence only existing to hurt
others and be sad hurt and alone unable
to even control my own actions what kind
of life is that if you can even call it
a life the monster hissed and said you
are
disgusting silently I agreed the town's
folks scream and run in Terror their
flaming torches and pitchforks falling
from their trembling hands behind them
scp096 Roars in monstrous rage it will
kill every single one of them and to
think this had been the happiest few
weeks of its life not long before scp096
is one of the most fearsome anomalies
ever contained by the SCP Foundation
responsible for nearly as many
containment breaches and personal
casualties as SCP 682 the shy guy is
known for only a few things it's long
pale limbs its tendency to huddle in the
corner of its cell weeping and the fact
that anyone who sees its face is doomed
to meet a horrible violent fate most of
the researchers and civilians alike who
have crossed scp096 is past would have
no trouble describing it as a monster
and some might even use stronger
language than that but though scp096 is
certainly frightening to behold and
often deadly to those who behold all of
it the shy guy is not a monster not to
everyone once upon a time it even had a
friend many many years ago before the
SCP Foundation First contained scp's own
96 it was just a pale figure that hid
from sight in the dense snowy Forest on
a remote mountain side there its long
lanky body and unnaturally pale
complexion allowed the creature to blend
in with the landscape skin-like snow and
arms and legs like branches and slender
tree trunks no one ever came into its
domain save for the occasional lost
hiker and it was easy enough for the
shyi to duck out of sight when they did
come in the warmer months Crews of
lumberjacks would come through and the
shy guy would have to be more careful
with its hiding moving quickly to keep
its face obscured from The Strangers
none of them ever saw its face though
they could feel its presence they would
whisper amongst themselves about the
feeling of being watched recalling old
Lumberjack Legends of the hide behind a
creature that stalked through forests
and hid itself behind the trees whenever
its prey turned to look the shy guy was
not trying trying to hunt them it only
wanted to be left alone but the
Lumberjacks still glanced over their
shoulders nervously as they went about
their work swapping scary stories around
the campfire at night when the work was
done but other than a rustling Branch a
flash of white darting between the trees
or the occasional set of unnaturally
large footprints in the snow they never
saw the creature they could sense
sharing the woods with them it was for
the best that they didn't they wouldn't
have survived if they had managed to
catch a glimpse of its face the shy guy
was happy with its home or at least as
happy as it could be about anything in
its life it was a lonely existence never
letting anyone truly see it the
creature's life was ruled by fear and
isolation the terror that one day its
face would be spotted and it would be
unable to control what it did next late
at night when the world was asleep save
for a few owls nestled in the branches
up above and scanning the ground for
mice to eat the shyi would let itself
truly feel the weight of its suffering
crying so hard its sobbs shook the tree
line but other times when the land was
still and quiet when a fresh snowfall
blanketed the Earth and soft white
powder and all living things were hiding
in a warm place until Springtime came
scp096 felt something like peace the
dead of winter was its safest time a
time where wouldn't need to listen for
every sound and await potential
Intruders but of course winter never
lasted eventually spring would always
come the first Blades of green grass
would poke up through the melting snow
and life would return to the shy Forest
one day the shy guys guard dropped and
it made a grave mistake it allowed
someone to get too close before looking
for hiding spot a man from one of the
lumber camps setting up nearby saw the
creature's face the man screamed in
shock and Terror but his screams were
soon drowned out by the raw animalistic
Bellow of the shy guy as it flew into an
uncontrollable frenzy of rage and
despair chasing the man through the
forest at Breakneck speed it was far
faster than the man running on longer
stronger legs than any human could have
when it caught up to the man in a
foreign part of the forest that the
creature had not seen before it silenced
his screams for good all at once the
creature was alone once more then came
the remorse the inevitable feeling of
deep devastating loss that came over it
every time it destroyed a person who had
seen its face the same cycle over and
over again Relentless and unceasing
though it should have gotten used to the
whole thing by now it broke the poor
creature's heart succumbing to sadness
SC scp096 slumped to the ground cradling
its head in its massive hands and began
to cry are you all right there are you
hurt a voice suddenly interrupted the
creature's private lament it froze at
the sound before lifting its head to
seek out the source of the interruption
who was that where were they did it have
time to hide before they could see its
face the shy guy opened its eyes to see
an old man standing only a few feet away
from it holding a cane the man was
facing it his eyes aimed towards the shy
guy's face but they were unfocused they
could not see the shy guy didn't
entirely understand how but it knew that
the man was unable to see its face for
the first time in a very long time it
felt relief wash over it you stopped
crying can you speak the man walked
closer to the creature concern furrowing
in his brow here take my hand and come
inside where it's warm I'll get you a
blanket and something to eat the old man
held out his hand expectantly and slowly
hesit ently scp096 placed its hand in
his my you're a big fellow if you can
stand come with me we'll get you all
sorted out unsure but too surprised to
do anything else the shy guy silently
followed the old blind man into a nearby
cabin inside it was indeed warm a small
yet Pleasant space lit by a crackling
fire in the Hearth it was the nicest
place as CP 096 had ever been cozy and
dry no snow or mud to be found every
surface was smooth or soft made for
living comfortably the old man led the
creature to a little dining table and
pulled out a chair inviting it to sit
down he prattled on about how nice it
was to have some company for once even
if his new companion was unable to speak
he had plenty to say and was happy to
fill the silence enough for the both of
them he turned on a radio and it came to
life with the S Sound of Music and
crackling static then he busied himself
at the wood fire stove where a pot of
soup was simmering he poured two bowls
of soup one for him and one for the Shy
Guy and placed them both on the table
scp096 wasn't sure of what to make of
the cabin the soup or the spoon that the
old man handed it to go with the meal
after a moment of watching the old man
eat however it began to understand that
it was food it disregarded the spoon in
favor of picking up the bowl and
drinking straight from it the broth meat
and vegetables warmed the Creature From
the Inside Out in a way it had never
felt before and for once the shy guy
made a sound other than a screech or SOB
M the old man laughed delightedly and
agreed that the soup was indeed very
good the two ate the rest of their meal
and the old man placed a heavy blanket
on the couch for the creature inviting
it to stay for the night in fact it
could stay as long as as it wanted like
he had said the old man could really use
the company as well as an extra pair of
hands to help out around the house this
could he said be an arrangement that
benefited them both with that the old
man went to bed leaving the shy guy
alone for the night it considered
leaving while the man slept slinking
back off into the forest and
disappearing but as it pulled the
blanket over its body it felt a sense of
warmth and comfort enveloping it this
was a safe place one where no one would
catch it unaware and look at its face
maybe it could stay at least for a
little while before long the Shy Guy's
eyes closed and it drifted off to sleep
the Shy Guy and the old man quickly fell
into a routine from there the old man
taught the creature how to tidy up
around the cabin how to chop wood and
use it to keep the stove and fireplace
lit he showed it how to open cans of
beans and retrieve meat from the cabin
Smokehouse so they could fix their meals
and introduced the creature to all of
his favorite stations on the radio all
the while the old man talked telling the
creature stories of his life his time in
the Army how he met his wife how it felt
to lose her how difficult it was to
raise his children alone and how
rewarding it was to see them go off and
start families of their own during one
of these stories the old man remarked
that his family would be coming out to
visit soon and bring him some supplies
to help him through the rest of the
winter before the warm weather returned
the shy guys should have understood what
that meant should have planned to leave
before the Man's family arrived but it
was so overwhelmed by the joys of its
new life that it didn't even consider
the possibility in this moment it seemed
that things would always be perfect one
morning the shy guy awoke to the sound
of a knock at the door it jolted awake
at the sound gasping with fear the Old
Man rushed into the room grinning
excitedly he told the shy guy not to to
be afraid that it was only his son
coming to visit but as CP 096 panicked
it had to cover its face now as the old
man opened the door to welcome his son
inside the shy guy quickly buried his
face in his hands shielding it from the
young man's eyes though the young man
did not Doom himself by seeing the
creature's face he couldn't help but cry
out in shock at the sight of his
father's house guest he tried to explain
to his father that this was not an
ordinary man in need of shelter but
rather some sort of terrible monster he
described the shy guy to his father its
lack of clothing its emaciated form and
impossible height but the old man would
not listen to a word he shed his son out
of the cabin insisting that if he was
going to be rude to his guest then he
could go ahead and see himself out he
told his son that the shy guy no matter
how strange it might look had been a
great help and comfort to him and he
would not tolerate a rude word against
his new friend he slammed the door shut
then then apologized to scp096 for his
son's Behavior meanwhile his son was
distraught his poor father living alone
with a monster he could not sit idly by
while this continued he rushed into town
and told everyone all about what he had
seen local Lumberjacks spoke up with
their own stories telling him about the
legends of the hide behind and The
Lumberjack who had gone out on a job in
those woods and never returned home this
creature living with the old man
had to be the same monster the town's
people decided that enough was enough
and they were going to take back the
forest and handle this monster problem
once and for all they grabbed whichever
weapons they could find from hunting
rifles and kitchen knives to pitchforks
and torches all the while they worked
themselves up into a frenzy of fear and
anger before long the once peaceful
people of the Town had formed into an
angry mob with the old man's son at the
helm kill the monster they cheered as
they stormed into the forest and towards
the old man's cabin the old man opened
his door expecting to find his son
standing there again and was greeted
instead by everyone from his town armed
to the teeth and ready for a fight they
demanded to see the monster that he was
keeping inside when he refused A group
of men grabbed him by the arms dragging
him out of the cabin as he protested
they insisted that they were doing this
for his own good to protect him from the
hideous Beast he had unknowingly
welcomed into his own home he struggled
to break free but he was not as strong
as he had been in his Youth and he was
outnumbered scp096 watched as its friend
was pulled from the cabin and taken
outside and it was unable to stop itself
from intervening it ran out of the front
door where the angry mob was waiting
neither scp096 nor the mob were prepared
for what happened next when the dozens
of people standing there with their
pitchforks and torches all found their
eyes locked directly onto SCP 96's face
the creature had been upset before but
now it was positively Furious its mouth
stretched into a shriek that echoed off
the mountain side as it began to rip
through the crowd like tissue paper
massive arms swinging and knocking over
people left and right until no one was
left standing some of the town's people
tried to fight back to Pro at the
creature with their pitchforks or swipe
at it with the Flames of their torches
but the attacks didn't even slow the shy
guy down bullets fired from the feed of
hunting rifles ricocheted off the
creature skin not leaving so much as a
dent as it tore through the crowd by the
time it was through there was no one
left except for the old man and his son
the old man called out to the creature
asking what had happened asking if it
was all right but as always the creature
could not answer and even if it could it
wouldn't have said a word at that moment
it's Focus was elsewhere its eyes
trained on the old man's son the only
person who had seen its face and was
still alive the young man ran off into
the forest as fast as he could tripping
over his own feet as The Terror made him
too clumsy to see straight the attempt
to escape was in vain and the shy guy
took no time at all to catch up with him
he grabbed the young man in its hands
lifted him into the air as he squirmed
and fought to break free then it
unhinged its jaw and swallowed him whole
when the shy guy quieted all of its prey
disposed of it heard the voice of the
old man in the distance calling out for
his friend it knew then that it could
never go back to the only person who had
ever shown it kindness it would not be
safe for either of them instead it would
return to the deep deep forest to the
life of solitude but it would never
forget that time in the cabin or the
only man who ever made scp096
feel as if it wasn't a monster at all
the SCP Foundation specializes in
tracking down and containing anomalies
that are difficult to find and that
often will do anything they can to avoid
being found one anomaly in particular
hates being seen more than anything and
will punish anyone who looks at its face
with a horrific fate scp096 is a
mysterious creature not only because it
destroys anyone who sees what it truly
looks like no one is entirely certain
where it came from what exactly it is or
why it reacts so violently to being
perceived there are however several
theories as to the Shy Guy's origin and
none of them are particularly cheerful
some suggest an experiment gone wrong
others believe it to be the last
remaining member of an unknown species
of mountain dwelling humanoids but one
theory about SCP 96's origin stands out
as particular ularly tragic in nature in
this story scp096 was not always a long
limed pale Beast cowering in the corner
and hiding its face from the world it
was once an ordinary man like anyone you
might pass on the street he was
someone's son someone's friend a person
with hopes dreams and passions a human
being who through anomalous
circumstances Beyond his control was
made into a monster many years ago there
was a mountain ear named Jack all his
adult life he had been obsessed with
reaching higher and higher Peaks
climbing Every Mountain he could in
order to test his limits Pit himself
against the power of nature and bask in
the sweet reward that was the view from
the top it began as a sport a way to
build up strength while taking in
incredible natural beauty but over time
as he conquered increasingly difficult
challenges it became an obsession like
every Obsession eventually does clim
sing mountains began to take over his
life driving everything else away he
struggled to hold down a job his
marriage fell apart and his
relationships to his friends and family
became increasingly distant and strained
still he couldn't bring himself to care
much he spent his alone time in the
wilderness or ever so often embarking on
trips with other Mountaineers whether he
was going at it Solo or working with
others he was living for the climb over
the years he took on serot to in arent
Ina the AER in Switzerland and Denali in
Alaska he especially enjoyed climbing in
extreme cold rving the ice and snow as
he embarked on his climbs the few fellow
Mountaineers he kept up with gave him
the nickname Jack Frost after years of
refining his craft building his strength
he set his sights on the highest
mountain in the world his personal white
whale Mount Everest itself it was one of
the deadliest climbs in the world with
its staggering height storms and Frozen
graveyard of Fallen climbers dotting the
snowy surface but he was determined he
would not join the ranks of the Fallen
but instead be one of the Victorious
that reached the top of Everest and came
back down in one piece he could feel it
in his bones Jack arrived in Nepal with
a pack full of climbing equipment the
best boots money could buy and layers
upon layers of clothing to keep himself
warm on the journey to the summit he
lowered his goggles over his eyes
summoned his courage and prepared for
the incredibly difficult climb the cold
seeped into his core the winds nipped at
his face numbing his nose and leeching
through his gloves and boots as he went
but Jack pressed on he welcomed the
sensation the bite of it it was a
reminder that he was still here that he
was still alive as long as he could feel
the pain he knew he was all right he
knew that it was when the cold faded
away turned to paradoxical feelings of
warmth and sleepiness that a mountaineer
was truly in trouble as he navigated the
harsh mountain landscape Jack
occasionally let his eyes drift off
course taking in the sights around him
he could see shocks of blue green and
red the distant bright colors of boots
jackets and hats belonging to the Fallen
climbers that came before him those who
collapse from exhaustion who gave in to
altitude sickness or succumbed to the
cold momento Mory he said softly to to
himself these frozen bodies represented
that everpresent reminder of mortality
of death lurking just out of sight it
would not come for him though not today
not on this journey he wouldn't let it
the hours blurred together within the
crunch of the ice beneath his boots the
Dig of climbing hooks into the Earth the
tug of his trusty ropes as he ascended
ever higher Jack came to a stop there
was no next step to take nowhere higher
that he could go he had reached the
Summit the white whale was captured and
Everest was his for the very first time
he was truly on top of the world now
that he had made it to the highest point
there was the all-important task of
climbing back down at this altitude he
was still in the death zone the place
where human acclimatization was
impossible this was the tricky part the
point at which even the most experienced
of climbers might get lost in the
Euphoria of the achievement and might
let their attention slip any mistake
during his descent any misstep could be
the thing that cost him his life there
was no room for error and no time to
waste just as Jack prepared to make his
descent he saw a figure pulling itself
over the ridge from a distance it looked
like a fellow climber he noticed the
Curious lack of equipment and the way
the person seemed to be making their way
up the mountain with nothing but their
hands but perhaps they lost their pack
or left it behind for some some reason
the figure was dressed in all white from
their Hood to their boots with a large
pair of Black Mountain goggles covering
what little of their face wasn't
concealed by the hood uncertain if the
figure was in need of assistance and
surprised to see another Soul on the
mountain with him jack waved at the
figure everything okay he called there
was no response but the figure turned to
look at him at least he thought it was
looking at him he couldn't see its eyes
through the goggles but he felt the
distinct sens ation of it locking its
gaze with his just the same as soon as
the figure turned to look at him jack
began to feel strange the pain the sharp
sensation of the cold that he relied on
to ground himself and remember he was
really here began to blur around the
edges the feeling softened melting away
along with the ache in his muscles the
blurriness in his eyes the dry mouth
that had nagged at him for hours he felt
unbalanced unmowed a ship with no anchor
he couldn't explain why but the sudden
relief from the cold made his chest
tighten with Primal Terror he did not
feel like one man encountering another
on the mountain he felt the way he had
years ago when he came face to face with
a mountain lion staring down a predator
and remembering all of a sudden that
humans do not naturally sit at the top
of the food chain this figure this thing
it was no man it was no person Jack
prepared to continue his descent to get
away from the strange Intruder as
quickly as possible but his feet would
not obey him his eyes could not break
contact with the figure in white that
was slowly beginning to advance toward
him one slow step at a time it was in no
hurry it knew he was not going anywhere
anytime soon he trembled as the figure
Drew closer its inscrutable face hidden
beneath its hood and behind its goggles
he wished he could just see its face but
dreaded learning What secrets it was
hiding if only he could just unstick his
feet from the earth Break Free of this
spell that had fallen over him he could
Escape but no matter how much his
muscles strained how he gritted his
teeth with effort he couldn't get away
as the entity came closer the cold
snapped back into his body but something
was different it was heightened like
every icy Breeze and freezing wind
layered on top of itself hardening his
muscles to Rock crystallizing the very
blood in his veins he felt as if his
fingers if he tried to wriggle them
would snap off and fall to the ground
his eyes thrummed in their sockets his
lungs stretched to hold on to each
breath as the cold constricted its fist
around his chest he opened his mouth to
speak but his voice died in his throat
coming out in a weak Whisper of air now
the thing was close enough to touch him
and whatever Force had been holding him
still and upright released him it was as
if he were a marionette suspended in the
air and the Puppeteer released his
strings at once he crumpled to the snow
covered ground in a heap his cheek
pressed into the Earth his eyes trained
helplessly on the still advancing figure
his lip formed the word please though he
could not tell exactly what he was
begging for his life his freedom a
painless death perhaps he struggled to
push himself to his feet but all
strength had gone out of his limbs he
could barely lift his arm let alone
handle the weight of his whole body the
thing shaped like a man was right above
him glowering down through those opaque
goggles he still could not see its eyes
but somehow he could feel the way it was
looking at him hatred was radiating off
of it disdain and pure unadulterated
malice then it tilted its head to the
side thoughtfully and Jack's mind was
overwhelmed with images he felt the
Phantom sensation of sunlight on his
skin and springy green grass beneath his
bare feet he could see clear as day in
his Mind's Eye a forest in the middle of
summer Dew drops sparkling on the Petals
of wild flowers blowing in a gentle
sweet Breeze then he felt sand between
his toes smelled the Sea Breeze felt the
comfort and contentment of a nap on the
beach it was not offering these things
to him but something like them something
like peace it was offering him a gift
but he didn't want it he couldn't take
it he was Jack Frost damn it he thrived
in the cold the hardship he didn't want
some warm sleepy Fade Out of existence
if he went out it would be on his terms
doing the thing he had dedicated his
life to if he were going to lose his
life he wouldn't roll over and just give
it up it would need to be Pride from his
Frozen hands with every last bit of Str
strength he twisted his head away from
the entity's Gaze covering his face with
his hands it grabbed at him shaking his
shoulders trying to force him to uncover
his face and meet its gaze once more but
he didn't budge he wouldn't he couldn't
then he felt the energy shift as it
realized he had refused the gift that he
would not welcome the paradoxical
feelings of heat and security and slip
away as it was asking him to but it was
not a victory he swore he could hear a
voice in his mind
say very well you wish to be part of the
mountain I will make it so the world
went white as Jack's eyes rolled back in
his head his spine curving back until it
snapped his jaw cracked and distended
his arms and legs stretched out long and
twisted his body contorted at unnatural
angles as the entity began to rearrange
his very being as the agony ripped
through him snapping his bones and
tearing his muscles Jack kept his face
cradled in his hands he remained in that
position even as he cried his voice
horse as the pure fear and pain
overwhelmed his senses until he forgot
his own name forgot he was ever a man at
all when Jack was no more when something
else sat there in his place pale and
shivering body racked with sobbs the
king of the mountain turned and left him
there alone with his misery still he
would not uncover his face he would not
let himself be vulnerable and would not
look up days later a group of
Mountaineers reached the summit of
Everest and spotted a hairless figure
crouched in the snow weeping softly are
you all right one of them asked the
figure lifted its head slowly and locked
eyes with the strangers its eyes widened
in horror its mouth stretched impossibly
wide in a wordless scream of rage and
hurt and with nothing human left in its
mind or heart as CP 096 took its very
first victim hello SCP Foundation
Personnel welcome to Cognito hazards and
you episode reducted this video series
is intended to teach you about the
protocol surrounding the various Cognito
hazardous anomalies currently within
Foundation containment when you know
better you do better and both you and
the secrets of our great organization
can stay safe and as anyone familiar
with a good Cognito Hazard can tell you
knowing really can make a difference
today's episode is about the unique and
dangerous SCP
2316 before we begin repeat after me and
be sure to speak clearly into the
microphone in front of you I do not
recognize the Bodies In The Water a
little louder please thank you in order
to be educated about the following SCP
you must pass a vocal examination with a
cognitive resistance value of no less
than 14.5 through this video
presentation you will need to repeat the
phrase to ensure your score does not
drop below the approved threshold in the
event that you fail the test stay calm
and remain where you are until medical
staff can retrieve you remember safety
is a top priority when observing Cognito
hazards the safe way is the only way
you're a cog in a very important machine
and we wouldn't want to have to
terminate you now would we one more time
please I do not recognize the Bodies In
The Water very good remember that you do
not recognize them no matter what you
might think you see your thoughts can be
very unreliable when you're around SCP
2316 according to our files on the
matter SCP 2316 refers to an anomalous
phenomenon identified in a Small Town
Lake it appears as a collection of human
bodies floating in a group on the
surface of the water the exact number of
corpses is unknown but it has been
estimated to be anywhere between 45 and
200 though the bodies belong to
individuals many researchers theorize
that the bodies in the water which you
do not recognize and you have never
recognized share a collective
Consciousness they function it would
seem with a hive mind of sorts the
bodies do not act on their own but as
one now where does the Cognito Hazard
come into play it would seem that anyone
who looks at the body in the water or
learns too much about SCP 2316 as a
whole begins to believe the corpses
floating in the lake are people they
recognize perhaps they remember their
faces from childhood or High School
whatever the case may be they become
convinced that the bodies in the water
are familiar and that they must approach
them no matter how familiar they might
seem however you do not recognize the
Bodies In The Water if a person attempts
to enter the lake reaching out to
whatever instances of SCP 2316 they
think they recognize more bodies will
begin to appear the more bodies appear
the more familiar faces seem to manifest
and the deeper the person will venture
into the lake eventually the person is
lost within the Sea of bodies likely
drowning beneath the surface or simply
becoming one with the hive mind until
they too are one of the corpses there
none of the individuals who wandered
into the lake in search of an old friend
or classmate have ever been recovered
there have been no attempts to search
the lake for their bodies as it is
unknown what affect SCP 236 would have
on the team assigned to such a task
though we can guess that the outcome
would likely be extremely negative for
all involved those who do Venture into
the lake simply disappear never to be
seen again if you look too long at the
bodies in the lake perhaps their faces
would surface alongside the rest but
it's best not to think about that after
all we do not recognize the Bodies In
The Water Foundation Personnel are not
allowed to approach SCP 2316 under any
circumstances the lake is only permitted
to be observed via dummy probes
outfitted with video and audio recording
equipment no one is permitted to observe
any footage or audio files collected
unless they pass through a screening for
resilience to Cognito hazardous
anomalies the lake that holds SCP 2316
has been fenced off and is patrolled by
guards with no prior knowledge of or
exposure to SCP
2316 anyone who attempts to approach the
lake and break through the boundaries of
its quarantine will be seized and taken
to site 33 for examination anyone who
comes within 50 m of the lake is
considered lost and presume dead repeat
after me slowly and clearly into the
microphone I do not recognize the Bodies
In The Water good I almost believe you
let's continue only one Foundation
officer that entered the lake containing
SCP 2316 was ever stopped before they
could be lost their name has been
stricken from any official records and
you do not need to know it their
identity does not matter what matters is
the interview they gave following the
incident conducted by Dr Harrison in his
office Dr Harrison asked the anonymous
officer if they felt compelled to enter
the Water by an invisible force as if
pulled in they rejected this concept
entirely insisting that they entered the
water of their own free will they wanted
to see the bodies who appeared to them
as their friends they wanted to hear
what the bodies were saying upon
entering the water they saw the faces of
their friends other faces were
unfamiliar but became more familiar the
longer the officer stared at their
features these were faces they had known
their entire life but something about
them was just a little bit wrong it was
like the face of someone in a dream
where you can tell they are someone you
know and you can even identify who it is
supposed to be but something about them
does not quite look right your mind
could not perfectly put their face
together from memory even though the
feeling of familiarity Remains the faces
in the water peering up through the
darkness below were like those dream
addled Memories the faces in the water
did not open their mouths but somehow
they spoke to the officer just the same
they spoke of who they were and asked
for help they asked to be seen to be
touched they spoke of the foundation
accusing us of covering up their deaths
and keeping the world from remembering
what happened to them at this point in
the interview the subject became
agitated yelling at Dr Harrison and
refusing to be quiet guards intervened
holding the subject still as they fought
yelling at Dr Harrison repeating over
and over that they could hear the body
speaking to them every single one the
interview ended when the the guards
remove the subject from the room taking
them to the amnestics department to have
all memory of the Bodies In The Water
erase from their mind then they were
forgotten once more I do not recognize
the Bodies In The Water did you repeat
it good we do not recognize the Bodies
In The Water we can't the motivations of
SCP 2316 if it has any at all are
largely unclear there are those on the
research staff that theorize the hive
mind or Collective consciousness of the
bodies is not malevolent in nature it is
they believe simply trying to make sure
that a tragedy that occurred in that
lake is remembered perhaps many lives
were lost to an anomalous force in that
Lake and the impact of that massive
tragedy left behind an impression on the
location this impression manifests in
the form of bodies spontaneously
appearing in an impossibly well
preserved condition the Cognito Hazard
of SCP 2316 is not intended to kill
anyone or take them but rather to force
strangers to remember the people who
lost their lives to the lake this sense
of familiarity whether it is false or
not ensures that the dead will not be
forgotten or left alone after all no one
deserves to be left alone though there
have been lives lost to the Cognito
hazard according to the foundation it is
understandable why the bodies would want
to be recognized to have someone
somewhere know who they were to have
someone remember their names Jeremiah
finan Arthur Scott Denise
Clark where was I oh yes repeat after me
once again I do not recognize the bodies
in the water I do not recognize them I
do
not but that's a lie isn't it I I do
recognize them how could I not I know
them they're my friends do you recognize
them look at their faces don't fight the
memories look into their eyes the class
of 1975 they were supposed to graduate
that fall they were just kids group of
innocent kids lost to the dark and deep
what happened to them I can't quite
remember but I know that it mattered
enough for the foundation to keep the
secret and I know that somehow I survive
but I shouldn't have I should be there
with them I should be there there isn't
much time I can hear the guards coming
to retrieve me their footsteps
thundering down the hall I failed the
test and the alarm has gone off they
think I'm lost but I'm not I've never
been less lost in my entire life I've
finally woken up to the truth I remember
I have to go I have to return to the
lake fall of 1975 they went for a swim
my friends they're calling to me I can
hear them sole clearly even from so far
away their cries for help ringing in my
ears their voices curling around me
pulling me to the edge of the water the
guards will come for you too they'll
know you've seen this they'll call you
compromised they'll say I succumb to the
effects of the Cognito Hazard they'll
say you did too you'll fail their little
tests and they'll say that makes you
weak and broken but you cannot listen
they're lying it's not a hazard it's a
scream for help they're screaming and
the foundation keeps covering it up they
won't let us find them and they won't
tell us why I have to go back so we can
be together again there are signs posted
all around the lake danger drowning
Hazard those are a trick it's to keep me
out keep to to keep the truth from me
the barb wire Fen is around it it's just
another trick I'll climb over it rung
after rung I don't care if the barbs
tear my clothes or pierce my skin it's
worth it for the truth for the memory
and once I've climbed to the top I'll be
able to see there through the fog I can
see their faces their lips parted in a
constant cry their eyes wide looking for
me my friends my family every face
unlocking a memory long buried I know
them all and I must go further I can't
turn back now I have to wade into the
water let its chills soak into my
clothes down to my bones one step and
another deeper and deeper the water
lapping at my ankles my knees my thighs
the deeper I go the more sure I will be
that this is where I belong the water
will engulf my chest my neck until my
feet no longer touch the ground I will
be lost in it water flooding into my
mouth pouring into every opening I will
let my body sink down down down to the
bottom where they've been all this time
nestled in the dirt and the dust they've
been so patient but it's finally time
they're ready to be remembered to be
seen to be found they're waiting for me
and they're waiting for you too can you
hear them I'm going now you have to find
me you have to follow me don't let the
guards stop you don't let them wipe it
all away from your mind fight break free
and find the lake hop the fence make
your way into the water you can't leave
me there to fade away floating in the
cold with the rest can you hear us we're
waiting now go check out SCP 2317 the
devour of Worlds and SCP 4812 wrath for
more mind-bending and mysterious scps